GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS
THE SENATE WILL COME TO ORDER
WITH THE SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GILL
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. DARLEY. DODD
TERRAZZO. EGGMAN. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. GROVE. HURTADO JONES.
LAIRD. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
MIN NEWMAN. NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO ROCK. RUBIO.
SATO. SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK THANK YOU. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WOULD THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE?
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR ARCHULETA.
AFTER WHICH, PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LET US RECALL THAT WE
ARE IN GOD'S PRESENCE. OH, GOD
OF PEACE, WE SEEK REST FOR OUR
SPIRITS AND LIGHT FOR OUR
THOUGHTS. WE BRING OUR WORK TO
BE SANCTIFIED. OUR WORDS, OUR
WOUNDS TO BE HEALED, OUR HOPES
TO BE RENEWED. YOU IN WHOM WE
ARE ONE, LIFT US FROM THE
LONELINESS OF SELF, AND FILL US
WITH THE FULLNESS OF YOUR LOVE.
RISE US ABOVE THE LIMITS OF YOUR
DAILY IMPERFECTIONS, OUR DAILY
IMPERFECTIONS SEND US VISIONS OF
OUR LOVE THAT IS IN YOU AND OF
THE GOOD THAT WILL BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN US THIS DAY.
YOUR GREATNESS IS BEYOND OUR
PRAISE. AMEN AMEN. MEMBERS,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AND TO REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS, I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
GAME PLAN FOR OUR SESSION THIS
MORNING. I COULD HAVE EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION, IT IS OUR INTENTION
TO TAKE UP SOME BUDGET BILLS. SO
WE WILL BEGIN WITH ONE HERE ON
OUR FLOOR AS THE ASSEMBLY DEALS
WITH A COUPLE BUDGET BILLS ON
THEIR FLOOR. SO IT MIGHT REQUIRE
US TO JUMP AROUND ON OUR AGENDA
SOMEWHAT AS WE WAIT FOR THE
PROCESSES TO WORK THEIR WAY OUT
IN BOTH. IN BOTH HOUSES, IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT WE MAY TAKE SOME
THINGS OUT OF ORDER, INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY SOME ADJOURN AND
MEMORIES IF THAT'S REQUIRED, WE
DO HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR
TODAY. I KNOW YOU'RE ALL EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. AND WE HAVE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS, SO IT'S
A QUITE A LINEUP FOR US TO GO
THROUGH THIS MORNING. AND WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN, BY MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR WIENER FOR
A PROCEDURAL MOTION. SENATOR
WIENER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE
SENATE RULES AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILLS 107 154 AND 167.
YEAH, I RECOGNIZE SENATOR NILO,
QUESTION, MR. PRESIDENT.
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR. THE
AUTHOR? TAKE A QUESTION. HE WILL
. FOR WHAT PURPOSE? A QUESTION.
IS THAT. IS THAT A QUESTION TO
ME? NO. AUTHOR THROUGH YOU. A
MOTION QUESTION AS TO WHY THE
MOTION? I. SENATOR NEAL, LET ME
TRY TO RESPOND TO YOUR QUESTION,
THE MEASURE THAT HE HAS MOVED,
HE HAS MADE A MOTION IS ON
SECOND READING TODAY. HIS MOTION
WILL ALLOW IT TO BE CONSIDERED
BY THE BY THE HOUSE, BY THE
SENATE IMMEDIATELY. SO THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF THAT MOTION, TO
TAKE IT OUT OF OUR NORMAL ORDER
OF HEARING SO THAT WE COULD HEAR
IT TODAY. I I UNDERSTAND THAT,
BUT THAT STILL DOESN'T TELL ME
WHY WE NEED TO SUSPEND AND SPEED
UP THE PROCESS. MR. MISTER
PRESIDENT, WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
RESPOND? I'D LIKE.
TO SAY WE HAVE A BUDGET
DEADLINE. WE WANT TO MEET THE
BUDGET DEADLINE AND WE DON'T
WANT TO BE HERE TOMORROW. AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SAY NO. MR.
I, I CAN RESPOND. I DON'T KNOW
WHY THEY'RE NOT POND SORT OF
DUMB. SO, STEVE, STOP.
MEMBERS, IF WE COULD ASK,
MEMBERS, CAN WE RETURN TO OUR
SEATS, PLEASE? THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, LET ME JUST
REITERATE THE RESPONSE I GAVE TO
OUR BUDGET VICE CHAIR, EARLIER,
WHICH IS THAT IT IS THE RIGHT OF
A MEMBER TO ASK FOR THE
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES. THAT IS
WHAT SENATOR WIENER HAS DONE,
AND IT WILL BE APPROPRIATELY
FOLLOWED. I FOLLOWED THROUGH ON
BY THE HOUSE IN TERMS OF WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT TO SUPPORT THAT
OR NOT. OKAY, OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. I DO
OBJECT TO THE MOTION, AND I'LL
DEFER MY QUESTION UNTIL WE
DISCUSS THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
BILL. TERRIFIC. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY SO SENATOR WIENER HAS
ASKED TO SUSPEND THE RULES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. ARCHULETA? AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI NÓ. DODD. AYE. DORADO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO.
AYE AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE
LIMON. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I
MEAN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NO. NILO. NO. OKOBO BADYOU. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN UMBERG
. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GIL. LIMÓN
CHROBOG. STERN ON A VOTE OF 29
TO 7, THE SENATE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM 32.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 107,
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 107 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
STATE BUDGET TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BUDGET BILL.
SENATOR WIENER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, AB
107 IS THE BUDGET ACT OF 2024.
IT REPRESENTS A BUDGET PACKAGE
THAT INCLUDES $293 BILLION IN
TOTAL SPENDING, OF WHICH 211.3
BILLION IS GENERAL FUND. AND THE
BILL MAINTAINS 23.2 BILLION IN
COMBINED TOTAL RESERVES. AND THE
AND THE BUDGET IS BALANCE IN
BOTH THE 2024 2025 AND 20 2526
FISCAL YEARS, IT THE IT INCLUDES
$46.9 BILLION IN SOLUTIONS IN
2425 FISCAL YEAR AND 29.8
BILLION IN SOLUTIONS IN THE 2526
FISCAL YEAR. IN ORDER TO CLOSE
OUR BUDGET DEFICIT, HIGHLIGHTS
OF THIS BUDGET INCLUDE INCREASED
FUNDING FOR K THROUGH 14 PUBLIC
EDUCATION THÀNH GOING BEYOND
WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION, ENSURING INCREASED
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS IN FUTURE
BUDGETS AS WE PRIORITIZE THE
EDUCATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN AND MAINTAINS THE SAME
LEVEL OF PROGRAMMATIC SPENDING
AS THE MAY REVISION IN THE
BUDGET BEFORE US TODAY RESTORES
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS. CUTS FROM
THE MAY REVISE TO CORE PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING CALWORKS FOSTER CARE,
IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. IT
RETAINS ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE
SLOTS AND REJECTS A DELAY OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES RATE
INCREASES AS THE BUDGET
MAINTAINS FUNDING. FULL FUNDING
FOR OUR ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM AND FOR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS, THE
BUDGET REDUCES THE BUDGET OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
BY APPROXIMATELY $1 BILLION AND
PROTECTS REHABILITATION AND
REENTRY SERVICES, THE BUDGET
FUNDS PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
AND SUPPORT FOR CRIME VICTIMS,
AMONG OTHER ITEMS, THE BUDGET
PROTECTS MORE THAN $3 BILLION IN
CLIMATE RELATED INVESTMENTS BY
SHIFTING GENERAL FUND COSTS TO
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND, THE BUDGET THAT BEFORE US
TODAY REJECTS THE MAY REVISE
PROPOSAL TO PERMANENTLY
ELIMINATE OVER $2.4 BILLION IN
ANNUAL NEW HEALTH INVESTMENTS
SCHEDULED TO TAKE EFFECT JANUARY
1ST. INSTEAD, THE NEW
INVESTMENTS WILL BE DELAYED ONE
YEAR UNTIL JANUARY 1ST, 2026,
WITH $200 MILLION IN NEW
INVESTMENTS INSTEAD STARTING
THIS BUDGET YEAR, THE BUDGET
ALSO RESTORES $1 BILLION FOR THE
HOMELESS HOUSING AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM. HAP ROUND SIX RESTORES
SOME FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND APPROVES
$500 MILLION IN LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS, THIS BUDGET
REPRESENTS THE WORK OF 54 BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS FOR FOUR
HEARINGS OF THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE. IN ADDITION, OF
COURSE, TO ALL OF THE WORK IN
THE ASSEMBLY. I WANT TO THANK,
OUR PRO TEM, OUR BUDGET SUB
CHAIRS, AND ALL OF OUR BUDGET
STAFF FOR THE TREMENDOUS WORK
THAT THEY HAVE PUT IN TO THE
BUDGET BEFORE US TODAY, WHICH
BALANCES OUR BUDGET BOTH THIS
YEAR AND NEXT YEAR, AND PROTECTS
THE PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE MADE
AROUND EDUCATION, AROUND HEALTH
CARE, AROUND SUPPORTING SOME OF
THE MOST AT RISK AND
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. VÀ AND OUR CLIMATE
ACTION AGENDA. NHÀ. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
DISCUSSION. SENATOR NILO? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, I'LL
DISPENSE WITH THE QUESTION THAT
I HAD EARLIER, ACTUALLY, AND
JUST SPEAK TO THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE BUDGET BILL AS I DID
YESTERDAY IN IN COMMITTEE, THE
THIS BUDGET IS BALANCED
NOMINALLY. I REALIZE THAT OUR
BUDGET CHAIR DOESN'T AGREE WITH
THAT LAST COMMENT I MAKE, BUT I
STILL MAINTAIN THAT IS THE CASE,
WE HAVE, SEVERAL ITEMS IN THIS
BUDGET THAT ARE GOING TO CAUSE
PROBLEMS RAIMES FOR THE NEXT
BUDGET. AND IT'S EASY TO PREDICT
RIGHT NOW. FOR EXAMPLE, THE
HEALTH CARE MINIMUM WAGE, WHICH
WILL GO INTO EFFECT IN JULY,
THERE IS INADEQUATE FUNDS IN THE
BUDGET TO COVER THAT. EXCUSE ME,
$2 BILLION, EXPECTED EXPENSE.
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE, OUR HEALTH
COMMUNITY HAS BECOME WEARY OF US
, PLAYING AROUND WITH THE, THE
FUNDS FROM THE MCO TAX. AND SO
THEY ARE PLACING AN INITIATIVE
OF THEIR OWN ON THE BALLOT FOR
NOVEMBER THAT IN THE CALENDAR
YEAR OF 2025, WILL COST AN
ADDITIONAL $2.7 MILLION.
ESTIMATED THAT'S OVER TWO BUDGET
YEARS BECAUSE IT'S THE CALENDAR
YEAR 25, BUT NONETHELESS, IT'S A
SUBSTANTIAL EXPENSE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE INCLUDED,
REVENUE ESTIMATE THAT IS $77
BILLION HIGHER THAN THE LEDGE
ANALYSTS ESTIMATE. AND THIS TWO
PARTY BUDGET INCLUDES A REVENUE
ESTIMATE THAT IS $4 BILLION
HIGHER THAN THAT RIGHT NOW. WE
CAN ALWAYS QUESTION WHAT
REVENUES SHOULD BE. BUT AS I'VE
SAID MANY TIMES IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS, I'M ALWAYS,
MORE, RECEPTIVE TO THE ADVICE OF
THE BUDGET ADVISOR AS OPPOSED TO
THE BUDGET WRITER. DIFFERENT
PRESSURES ARE INVOLVED. AND AS
I'VE ALSO SAID MANY TIMES, ONE
OF THE EASIEST WAYS TO BALANCE
THE PUBLIC SECTOR BUDGET IS TO
JUST ASSUME MORE REVENUES. SO IN
THIS TWO PARTY BUDGET, I SEE
THAT AS AN $11 BILLION POTENTIAL
PROBLEM, ONCE WE GET THROUGH
THIS BUDGET YEAR, THERE IS ALSO
THREE UNKNOWN, IMPACTS. ONE IS
THE PROPOSITION 98 MAINTENANCE
FACTOR, WHICH WILL COST FUTURE
BUDGET YEARS, INCLUDING THE NEXT
ONE, ALSO IN THE GOVERNOR'S
RATHER CONFUSING, MEASURE WITH
REGARD TO THE 2223 PROPOSITION
98 OVERPAID THAT THAT CREATES AN
OBLIGATION ON THE GENERAL FUND.
IT'S A BASICALLY AN INTEREST
FREE LOAN, AND THAT WILL BE
ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURES IN
FUTURE BUDGET YEARS BUILT IN.
AND THE LAST ONE IS THE 8%
ACROSS THE BOARD CUT THAT IS TO
SAY, AGENCIES WITHIN THE
BUREAUCRACY ARE EXPECTED TO COME
UP WITH THEIR OWN, CUTS OF 8% OF
THEIR OWN EXPENDITURES, THAT IS
NOT GOING TO THE OVERSIGHT.
THAT'S PROVIDED. AND THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BUDGET BILL
NOTWITHSTANDING, I AM HIGHLY
SKEPTICAL OF THAT NUMBER. THOSE
THREE, I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THE IMPACT IS, BUT THE MAY
REVISE DID REDUCE THE OUTYEAR,
KNOWN PROBLEMS, WHICH WERE ABOUT
$30 BILLION A YEAR FOR 3 OR 4
YEARS, DOWN TO ABOUT 10 BILLION.
BUT THESE DIFFERENCES PUTS IT
BACK UP TO $30 BILLION AGAIN OR
VIRTUALLY AGAIN. THE BUDGET IS
BALANCED NOMINALLY, BUT IT IS
NOT SUSTAINABLE. AND ALL OF
THESE ISSUES WILL COME BACK TO
ROOST WHEN THE GOVERNOR NEEDS
TO, PRESENT HIS JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN JANUARY OF 2025. I
URGE A NO VOTE, NO VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR NILO. SENATOR DOLLY
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS. TODAY IS THE DAY THAT
WE ALL LOOK FORWARD TO THIS MOST
IMPORTANT, VOTE. I BELIEVE AS A
LEGISLATOR THAT YOU MAKE IS THE
BUDGET VOTE. IT'S ABOUT OUR
PRIORITIES. SO I WANT TO JUST
IDENTIFY IN THIS BUDGET, SOME OF
THE PRIORITIES AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT AREN'T PRIORITIES,
THAT I THINK WE'VE FAILED TO, TO
RECOGNIZE WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
$1.1 BILLION ON HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND 1.2 BILLION
TO BAIL OUT PUBLIC TRANSIT.
THAT'S A PRIORITY. BUT WE'RE
GOING TO CUT OVER $75 MILLION
FOR HOUSING FOR VETERANS. SO
JUST REMIND YOU THAT'S WHERE OUR
PRIORITIES AT HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND BAIL OUT OF TRANSIT OVER OUR
VETERANS. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
HEALTH CARE, WE HAVE THE MCO
BILL WE PASSED IT A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO, WHICH IS A TAX ON THE
HEALTH PLANS, WHICH GOES INTO
THE GENERAL FUND AND DOESN'T
FUND HOSPITALS. IT'S THERE'S $4
BILLION IN THE GENERAL FUND THAT
GOES TO UNDOCUMENTED. THAT'S THE
PRIORITY OVER HOSPITAL FUNDING.
NOW THE PEOPLE THAT WALKED
ACROSS THE BORDER YESTERDAY DID
NOT PARTICIPATE IN PAYING TAXES
OR ANYTHING, BUT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO GO TO OUR HOSPITALS AND
USE OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS. BUT
WE'RE NOT FUNDING THEM. SO I
THINK THAT'S A PRIORITY THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. WE HAVE
$20 BILLION TO FUND OFFSHORE
WIND, BUT WE'RE CUTTING CDCR BY
500 MILLION. SO PRIORITY IS WIND
OVER MAKING OUR STREETS SAFE A
PRIORITY TO FUND CALTRANS FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES $280 MILLION
TO REPLACE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. AS WE'RE CUTTING
BROADBAND FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND FOR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
GET ON THE INTERNET AND DO THEIR
HOMEWORK. NOW FOR MY LAST POINT,
AND THE ONE I TALK ABOUT EVERY
YEAR, THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA, ONE I'M VERY NEAR
AND DEAR TO YOU BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY OPERATE A BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA, AND IT'S ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST PLACES IN THE COUNTRY
TO DO BUSINESS. IF YOU RECALL,
DURING THE PANDEMIC, WHEN
UNEMPLOYMENT WAS RAMPANT, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BORROWED
MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PLAY ON PAY
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. WE, THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY, HAS TO PAY
BACK THAT MONEY, NOT THE STATE.
WHEN WE HAD FRAUD, BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF FRAUD,
AND THAT SADDLED ON THE BACKS OF
THE BUSINESSES. $18.8 BILLION.
WE STILL OWE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THAT'S THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE. SO IF YOU'RE OPERATING A
BUSINESS IN THIS STATE THIS
BUDGET IS GOING TO PAY THE
INTEREST $500 MILLION, EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
AGENCY THAT SQUANDERED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
NET, OPERATING. SO IN A IN YOU
CAN EITHER RAISE TAXES OR YOU
CAN TAKE AWAY TAX DEDUCTIONS. $5
BILLION IN TAX DEDUCTIONS ARE
COMING AWAY FROM BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THE NET OPERATING
LOSS. NOW I KNOW THAT I ALWAYS
ASK EVERY YEAR SHOW ME ONE THING
IN THIS BUDGET, BUDGET THAT'S
GOING TO HELP KEEP A BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. JUST ONE. AND I
CHALLENGE YOU TO SHOW ME WHAT
KEEPS BUSINESSES TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I CAN'T FIND
ANY. NOW, I KNOW YESTERDAY
DURING THE BUDGET HEARING, WE
HEARD ABOUT THE TAP FUNDING,
WHICH $23 MILLION GOES TO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
STARTUP BUSINESSES, SMALL
BUSINESSES. WE HEARD A LOT OF
FOLKS TALK ABOUT THAT. THAT'S
GREAT. THAT'S THE START OF
BUSINESS. THAT'S NOT TO KEEP A
BUSINESS RUNNING IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S THE START OF BUSINESS. SO
I THINK WE SHOULD FOCUS MORE ON
THE PEOPLE THAT PAY THE ORIGINAL
TAX. OUR BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA PAY THE ORIGINAL TAX.
YOU CANNOT HAVE A STRONG PUBLIC
SECTOR UNLESS YOU HAVE A STRONG
PRIVATE SECTOR. AND SO I WANT TO
JUST END BY SHARING SOME
STATISTICS I'VE WORKED ON FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS. I
HAVE EVERY SINGLE DISTRICT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT
HERE. YOU'RE WELCOME TO LOOK AT
IT, OF BUSINESSES HAVE LEFT YOUR
DISTRICTS AND LEFT CALIFORNIA.
THESE ARE THESE ARE HIGH PAYING
JOBS. THERE ARE THERE ARE GREEN
JOBS. AND I'M JUST GOING TO TAKE
THE TOP FIVE DISTRICTS AND JUST
NAME OFF A FEW. SO IN SENATE
DISTRICT TEN WE'VE LOST 36
COMPANIES, $264 MILLION BATTERY
PLANT WENT TO KENTUCKY, TESLA
MOVED TO NEVADA. 5000 JOBS IN
SENATE DISTRICT 11. 122
COMPANIES. OVER HALF OF THOSE
WERE HEADQUARTERS. THAT LEFT FOR
OTHER STATES. AND I HAVE A LIST
OF ALL THE PLACES THEY WENT
TEXAS, TENNESSEE, FLORIDA,
SENATE DISTRICT 1369 COMPANIES,
INCLUDING GOOGLE, TESLA, ORACLE,
JOHNSON AND JOHNSON WORLDWIDE
COMPANIES LEAVING CALIFORNIA.
SENATE DISTRICT 1533 COMPANIES.
APPLE WENT TO HOUSTON, TEXAS.
NETFLIX. SENATE DISTRICT 2663
COMPANIES, INCLUDING BILLION
DOLLAR SOLAR ENERGY COMPANIES.
GREEN JOBS LEAVING CALIFORNIA
AND THE LAST ONE SENATE DISTRICT
3739 COMPANIES. RIVIAN $5
BILLION PLANT EXPANSION
PANASONIC SOLAR MANUFACTURING
PLANTS, $2.5 BILLION. FOLKS,
LOOK, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
SOME TIME THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IF WE DON'T HAVE
BUSINESSES, WE DON'T HAVE A TAX
BASE TO DO ALL THE THINGS WE
NEED TO DO IN GOVERNMENT. WE
NEED TO SUPPLY HEALTH CARE. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE OUR STREETS
AND ROADS ARE SAFE. ABSOLUTELY.
AND WHEN WE KEEP OUR STREETS
STRAIGHT, BUT WE'RE NOT DOING A
VERY GOOD JOB WHEN IT COMES TO
KEEPING THE TAX PAYING
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. SO
UNTIL WE START FOCUSING ON HOW
WE KEEP BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
AND KEEP THEM SAFE, THEY'RE
GETTING RANSACKED BY CRIMINALS.
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON
THEY'RE SHUTTING DOWN AND
LEAVING. WE NEED TO DO A BETTER
JOB. FOR THOSE REASONS, I CAN'T
SUPPORT AB 107, AND I URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR DOLLY.
SENATOR CIERTO THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M GOING TO BE
JOINING MY COLLEAGUE TODAY IN
VOTING NO ON THE BUDGET. AND
HERE'S WHY. VERY SIMPLY, THE
BUDGET DOES NOT REFLECT THE
PRIORITIES OR NEEDS OF MY
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT. WE
COME FROM A VERY DISTRICT, A
VERY DIFFERENT DISTRICT THAN A
MAJORITY OF THIS HOUSE. AND THE
ASSEMBLY. THIS BUDGET REFLECTS.
YES, IT DOES REFLECT THE
GOVERNOR'S, PRIORITIES. THAT
REFLECTS THE PRIORITIES OF A
MAJORITY, THE SUPER MAJORITY OF
THE LEGISLATURE. BUT DON'T LULL
YOURSELVES INTO THINKING THAT
SOMEHOW, BECAUSE IT REFLECTS
THOSE PRIORITIES, THAT THOSE ARE
THE PRIORITIES OF THE NORMAL
CITIZENS OUT THERE, THAT RIGHT
NOW ARE BEING HAMMERED. GO OUT
INTO YOUR DISTRICTS AND SIT
THERE, DON'T TALK, BUT LISTEN,
AND YOU WILL FIND A LOT OF
UNHAPPY CUSTOMERS. AND HERE'S
THE THING WITH OUR BUDGET, WE
HAVE A REVENUE AND SPENDING
PROBLEM. AND WHEN WE DON'T MAKE
ENOUGH REVENUES, THE ANSWER
CAN'T BE, WELL, LET'S DO SOME
HIDDEN TAXES FOR BUSINESSES AND
KEEP RAISING TAXES. SO WE DO
THAT BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS YOU'RE DRIVING OUT THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO HELP
SUPPORT YOUR ECONOMY. THE WAY TO
FIX A REVENUE AND SPENDING
PROBLEM IS TO ENSURE THAT YOU'RE
NOT SPENDING MORE THAN YOU'RE
TAKING IN, AND WHAT YOU'RE
TAKING IN HAS TO DEPEND ON A
POSITIVE ECONOMY. VÆ WE ARE NOT.
WE ARE NOT PROMOTING A POSITIVE
ECONOMY. YES, WE ARE BECAUSE OF
OUR SIZE. WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
THE FOURTH OR FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD, BUT WE
SURE DON'T REFLECT THAT, NOT IN
THE PAIN THAT OUR PEOPLE ARE
FEELING OUT THERE. AND THIS
BUDGET DOESN'T DO THAT. AS MY
COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT. LOOK AT
THOSE PRIORITIES. IN THE
MEANWHILE, PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
HOMES. AND YET WE'VE BEEN TRYING
WE'VE BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS OUR
PRIORITY IS MAKING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OUR PRIORITY IS THE
HOMELESS. WE SPENT $20 BILLION
ON THE HOMELESS, AND THEY'RE
STILL HOMELESS. OUR KIDS ARE
STILL UNABLE TO AFFORD A HOUSE.
THEY'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT
LEAVING BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
GREAT JOBS FOR THEM BECAUSE
WE'VE CHASED OUT ALL THOSE GREAT
JOBS. WE HAVE TO ADJUST THE WAY
WE THINK. IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE OPTIMAL PLACE TO
LIVE. AND AN AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
LIVE, THIS BUDGET DOESN'T
REFLECT THAT KIND OF AN EFFORT.
IT DOESN'T FIX OUR ROADS. IT
DOESN'T FIX OUR FIX OUR FLOOD
ISSUES OUT IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY OR IN MY DISTRICT. IT
DOESN'T BRING US A BUNCH OF MORE
JOBS. IT DOESN'T INCENTIVIZE
JOBS FROM COMING IN. IN FACT, IT
PILES ON MORE STUFF TO
DISINCENTIVE BUSINESSES FROM
COMING IN AND GIVING PEOPLE
JOBS. THAT'S HOW WE GET OUT OF
AN ECONOMY. PEOPLE WORKING PAY
THEIR NORMAL TAXES. BUT RIGHT
NOW WE GOT LESS AND LESS PEOPLE
WORKING. AND GUESS WHAT? LESS
AND LESS PEOPLE ARE PAYING
TAXES. AND IF WE KEEP RAISING
THE TAXES ON THOSE, WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE EVEN LESS PEOPLE DOING
THAT. WHAT WE'RE DOING DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE AT SOME POINT.
WHETHER WE HAVE A SUPERMAJORITY
OR NOT, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE
THIS OUT, AND THE SOONER THE
BETTER, BECAUSE THE LONGER WE
LET IT GO ON, THE WORSE IT'S
GOING TO GET. I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SATO. SENATOR
GROVE, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I TOO, RISE IN OPPOSITION AND
JOIN MY COLLEAGUES ON AB 107. IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS, COLLEAGUES,
THE GOVERNOR AND THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS GONE FROM A $100
BILLION BUDGET SURPLUS TO A 50
BILLION OR 50 5 BILLION OR 62
BILLION, WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS,
TODAY, IT'S BEEN DIFFERENT
THROUGHOUT THE LAST FEW WEEKS,
WE SPENT $24 BILLION ON HOMELESS
PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE NO PROGRESS
TO SHOW FOR IT. OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION HAS ACTUALLY GOTTEN
WORSE. AND THAT'S LEFT
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE HIGHEST
ENERGY COST. WHEN WE SPEND ALL
THIS MONEY ON CLIMATE,
CALIFORNIANS PAY THE HIGHEST
ENERGY COST IN THE NATION,
HIGHEST UTILITY RATES IN THE
NATION, SOME OF THE HIGHEST GAS
PRICES IN THE NATION. IT'S
BECOMING VERY, VERY UNAFFORDABLE
FOR EVERYDAY PRODUCTS. AND WE
KEEP DUMPING MONEY INTO THESE
PROGRAMS. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST ENERGY PRICES. LIKE I
SAID, IN THE COUNTRY, AND
DESPITE MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
KNOWING AGAIN AND THE REASON,
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS I'M
OBJECTING TO THIS BUDGET IS
THERE'S $105 BILLION GOING TO
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL THROUGH
OTHER FUNDS AND SOURCES, BUT
IT'S STILL BEING ALLOCATED WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS FOR A
MINUTE. PROP ONE WAS PASSED IN
2008. THERE WAS A PROMISE THAT
ALL OF US TODAY WOULD LEAVE THIS
BUILDING, NOT GET ON AN
AIRPLANE, AND WOULD BE ON THIS
TRAIN GOING, YOU KNOW, 200 MILES
AN HOUR FROM SAN DIEGO TO SAN
FRANCISCO OR TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THERE'S NOT ONE BIT OF
TRACK CONNECTED. I THINK IT'S
LESS THAN ONE MILE OF TRACK
THAT'S AVAILABLE. THEY HAVEN'T
SECURED ALL THE LANDS. BUT THE
BIGGEST IRONY OF STILL FUNDING
THIS PROJECT IS SIGMA. YOU GUYS
TAKE GROUNDWATER FROM FARMERS
THAT GROW FOOD. I REPRESENT THE
TOP THREE FOOD PRODUCING
COUNTIES IN THE WORLD. YOU TAKE
THEIR WATER, DON'T ALLOW THEM TO
ACCESS WATER ON THEIR OWN LAND.
AND THE REASON AND THE SCIENCE
THAT YOU SAY IS BEHIND THAT IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A SINKING VALLEY
FLOOR. BUT YET THIS BUDGET
ALLOCATES OVER A BILLION WITH A
B DOLLARS TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT. THAT IS A MULTI TON
CEMENT PROJECT MONSTROSITY THAT
I PASS EVERY WEEK GOING UP AND
BACK ON 99 AND YOU'RE BUILDING
IT ON A SINKING VALLEY FLOOR UP
TO 28FT IN THE LAST TWO DECADES.
DO YOU THINK THAT THAT THING IS
GOING TO SURVIVE ANYTHING, EVEN
IF IT IS BUILT? LOOK AT IT. LOOK
AT GOOGLE RIGHT NOW. CENTRAL
VALLEY SINKING FLOOR. THAT'S WHY
YOU IMPLEMENTED SIGMA. SO WE
WOULD STOP TAKING WATER OUT OF
THE GROUND AND STOP THE VALLEY
FROM SINKING OR HAVING
SUBSIDENCE IS THE CORRECT WORD.
SO JUST THINK ABOUT THAT. THIS
BUDGET, THIS BILLION DOLLARS
COULD GO TO FUND OUR HEALTH
CARE, OUR HOSPITALS. I CAN LOOK
OUT HERE AND PROBABLY COUNT TO
NINE LEGISLATORS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE WHERE WE HAVE
HOSPITAL AND, MATERNITY WARDS
AND LABOR AND DELIVERY WARDS
CLOSING. WE HAVE EMERGENCY ROOMS
GOING ON STANDBY, AND WE'RE NOT
FUNDING OUR HOSPITALS AND MAKING
SURE THAT OUR PEOPLE, THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT WE REPRESENT,
HAVE HEALTH CARE. BUT YOU WANT
TO FUND A PROJECT. I MEAN, THAT
CEMENT HAS GOT TO WEIGH HUNDREDS
OF TONS ON OUR SINKING VALLEY
FLOOR. JUST THINK ABOUT THAT FOR
A SECOND. IT'S A MULTI-BILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT. NO PROMISES FROM
PROP ONE. A HAVE EVER BEEN
FULFILLED. I JUST ASK YOU JUST
TO TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND IT
DOESN'T TAKE A LOT. YOU DON'T
EVEN HAVE TO SAY WE MADE A
MISTAKE. YOU CAN BLAME IT ON THE
VOTERS FOR APPROVING IT BY 53,
BUT YOU CAN TAKE A STAND AND
SAY, LOOK, WE'RE IN A BUDGET
DEFICIT. WE GOT A BILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO THIS PROJECT.
IT'S NOT GOING TO MEET OR EXCEED
ANY TYPE OF DEADLINE THAT
THEY'VE EVER SET. YOU KNOW, IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE ON A 2020
DEADLINE. NOW IT'S 2030, IT'LL
GO TO 2050, 2060, AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO DUMP MONEY IN IT.
BUT WE CAN COVER A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE CUT OUT OF THIS BUDGET
THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED,
DESPERATELY NEED SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES $27 MILLION. MY
COLLEAGUE THAT I SHARE
BAKERSFIELD WITH THAT IS JUST TO
THE NORTH AND SURROUNDING ME, WE
HAVE COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
WATER. THEY GO OUT FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AND CURRENTLY ADDING TO
THAT COMMUNITY, YOU TURN ON THE
FAUCET, THEY DON'T HAVE WATER.
THESE ARE FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES
. THEY GO OUT SELF HELP, BRINGS
THEM THIS BIG BLACK TANK, FILLS
IT WITH WATER AND THEY HAVE
WATER TO WASH THEIR CLOTHES AND
DISHES. IT'S CALIFORNIA AND OUR
FARM WORKER FAMILIES LIKE
TUBERVILLE, OTHER AREAS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY DO NOT HAVE RUNNING
WATER. WE COULD USE THAT BILLION
DOLLARS TO HOOK THEM UP TO CITY
WATER IN A HEARTBEAT. WOULDN'T
EVEN USE A FRACTION OF IT. SO
THAT'S A PRIORITY THAT IS
OVERLOOKED. YOU CUT $17.5
MILLION OUT OF SELF-HELP AT A
SELF-HELP. IT'S AN ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS WITH COMMUNITIES TO
CONNECT THEM TO WATER, WATER,
WATER. YOU NEED TO LIVE HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN A PROJECT THAT'S
OVER BUDGET AND OVER TIME. BUILT
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED THIS YEAR TO
FUND. I LOOK AT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY COMMUNITIES THAT WE
REPRESENT AND I WAS TALKING TO
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES AND I'M NOT
GOING TO SAY WHO IT WAS, BUT I'M
TALKING IT'S LIKE I WENT DOWN TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND YOUR BAR
IS REALLY LOW, LIKE YOUR BAR IS
YOU JUST WANT ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND YOU WANT TO GROW FOOD
AND YOU WANT TO KEEP YOUR JOB.
I'M LIKE, YEAH, WE DON'T DEMAND
A LOT. WE DON'T. WE MAINTAIN
MORE MILES OF ROAD THAN ANY
OTHER DISTRICT, MORE MILES. BUT
ROAD DISTRIBUTIONS ARE BASED ON
POPULATION. SO WE DO IT FOR LESS
MONEY. SO OUR ROADS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE CRUMBLING.
BUT YOU GUYS WILL DUMP $1
BILLION INTO HIGH SPEED RAIL
THAT IS NOT EVEN OPERATIONAL,
NOT EVEN CLOSE TO BEING
OPERATIONAL. IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE BUILT IN OUR LIFETIME. WHY
NOT JUST SUSPEND THAT MONEY AND
SPEND THAT BILLION DOLLARS ON
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL CARE
ABOUT, LIKE HEALTH CARE, ACCESS
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS? I HAVE A
HOSPITAL IN RIDGECREST THAT'S
FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED. WE GOT A
LITTLE BIT OF MONEY TO THEM. IT
LET THEM SURVIVE, THAT LABOR AND
DELIVERY DEPARTMENT HAS CLOSED.
IT IS AN HOUR AND TEN MINUTES TO
THE NEXT AVAILABLE HOSPITAL. AN
HOUR AND TEN MINUTES. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER MENTIONED
THAT WE'RE CUTTING ALL THESE
VETERANS BENEFITS. THERE ARE
VETERANS ON THIS FLOOR THAT HAVE
PUT THEIR HAND IN THE AIR AND
SWORE TO DEFEND THIS COUNTRY
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC. THEY ARE LIVING ON THE
STREETS AND THEY DESERVE BETTER.
$75 MILLION FROM THEIR HOUSING
PROJECTS. BUT YOU'RE SPENDING
$1.5 BILLION ON HIGH SPEED RAIL.
YOU COULD ADD UP A WHOLE LOT OF
THINGS THAT EVERY ONE OF US
DEEPLY CARE ABOUT, THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE TALKING ABOUT
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND IT WOULD
NOT EVEN MEET THE $1 BILLION
GOING OUT THE DOOR TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL. AND I REALIZE IT'S A
COMBINATION OF FUNDS AND NOT
DIRECTLY FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
ANOTHER THING THAT BOTHERS ME A
LOT ABOUT THIS BUDGET IS WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER AGAIN
MENTIONED. FROM THE BUSINESS
ASPECT, EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR THAT
COMES INTO THIS BUDGET IS FROM A
SMALL BUSINESS OR A LARGE
BUSINESS. IT'S FROM A BUSINESS.
AND I KNOW YOU GUYS WERE LIKE, I
PAY TAXES TOO. I PAY TAXES OUT
OF MY CHECK. BUT YOUR ORIGINAL
CHECK COMES FROM A BUSINESS
PAYING TAXES, EMPLOYING PEOPLE
TO PAY TAXES, PAYING PROPERTY
TAXES, PAYING PERMIT FEES LIKE
THE WATER BOARD IS 100% INDUSTRY
FUNDED. CAL JIM IS 100% INDUSTRY
FUNDED. THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS OR AGENCIES THAT
ARE 100% INDUSTRY FUNDED. EVERY
SINGLE DOLLAR COMES FROM THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. YOU CAN SAY,
WELL, I INVEST MONEY AND I DO
THIS, BUT YOU EARN THAT MONEY
THROUGH A BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
AND EVEN IF IT WAS, IT WAS AN
INHERITANCE. IT CAME ORIGINALLY
FROM A BUSINESS. IF YOU TRACK IT
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO ITS SOURCE.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS HURTING
OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY WHILE
WE'RE STILL REELING FROM THE
FACTS THAT WE HAVE A $32 BILLION
FOOD TAX REDUCTION CREDIT
BECAUSE OF THE FRAUD AND ALL THE
ED THAT WAS OVERDRAFTED FROM THE
FEDERAL ACCOUNT, AND IT'S
COSTING OUR BUSINESSES AN
ADDITIONAL 6.9% EVERY SINGLE
YEAR TO PAY THAT LOAN BACK. THAT
MEANS A SMALL BUSINESS WITH SO
MANY EMPLOYEES, CALLED $1
MILLION A YEAR IN PAYROLL, HAS
$100,000 BILL DUE AT JANUARY. AS
SOON AS THAT BILL COMES AND
THEY'VE GOT TO COME UP WITH THE
MONEY TO PAY IT. SO WE'RE STILL
ADDRESSING THAT. WE'RE STILL
ADDRESSING EMPLOYEES TRYING TO
COME BACK FROM COVID. WE SHOULD
REALIZE THAT BECAUSE WE ALL SIT
ON COMMITTEES AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE STAFF REDUCTIONS AND
NOT BEING ABLE TO GET STAFF
FILLED FOR GOVERNMENT AGENCIES,
YOU KNOW, WHY IS IT HOW CAN WE
CAN'T GET STAFF? WELL, WE'RE
TRYING WE'RE RECRUITING, WE'VE
DONE THIS. WE'RE RUNNING ADS,
WE'RE RUNNING SOCIAL MEDIA. SO
WE HAVE THE SAME PROBLEMS AS A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER. A LOT OF
US IN THIS, A LOT OF US, I SAY,
A LOT OF US, SEVERAL OF US IN
THIS BUILDING ARE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND WE GET IT. SO THE
ATTACKS ON BUSINESS IS
COMPLETELY BE JUST RIDICULOUS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE
SQUANDERING A BILLION PLUS
DOLLARS IN A HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM THAT HAS NO CHANCE OF
EVEN BEING BUILT IN OUR
LIFETIME. AND IF YOU TAKE ALL
THAT MONEY, SHOOT, WE COULD FUND
A LOT OF THINGS THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS, LIKE I SAID
EARLIER, REALLY, REALLY DO CARE
ABOUT. RESPECTFULLY ASK A NO
VOTE ON THIS. I THINK WE SHOULD
LOOK AT PRIORITIES. DEFINITELY.
OUR PRIORITIES SHOULD NOT BE
SPENDING OVER $1 BILLION ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL. WHEN YOU CAN'T PUT
VETERANS IN HOUSING AND YOU
CAN'T EVEN PROVIDE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE, AND YOU CAN'T KEEP
YOUR PROMISE ON THE MCO TAX FOR
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE HEALTH
HEALTH CARE TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE MEDI-CAL RECIPIENTS,
THE POOREST COMMUNITIES AT A
CONSTITUENT CALL, GETTING INTO
MEDI-CAL. AND HE'S LIKE, THEY
CAN'T SEE ME FOR FOUR MONTHS.
THEY CAN'T SEE ME FOR FOUR
MONTHS BECAUSE THERE ARE VERY
FEW DOCTORS PROVIDING THAT
BECAUSE THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
ON MEDI-CAL RATES ARE SO LOW, SO
LOW THAT IT'S A PATHWAY TO
BANKRUPTCY. SO WHY TREAT THAT?
AND THAT'S THE POOREST OF OUR
POOR THAT YOU GUYS ALL SAY YOU
CARE ABOUT. THAT BILLION DOLLARS
WOULD GO A LONG WAY. WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
AND PUT OUR PRIORITIES IN PLACE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SENATOR
MCGUIRE, THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PLAN.
AS WE ALL KNOW, CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET IS COMPLICATED. IT'S BIG,
IT'S BOLD AND WE ARE WORKING TO
GET THIS JOB DONE. AND TODAY
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD. THIS YEAR
WE HAVE FACED SOME CHALLENGES IS
THAT THIS STATE HASN'T SEEN IN
MANY YEARS, AND THE PIECES HAVE
COME TOGETHER IN THIS SPENDING
PLAN, WHICH IS THE RESULT OF
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF
TESTIMONY ANALYSIS AND DOZENS
UPON DOZENS OF MEETINGS WITHIN
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES. AND,
OF COURSE, OUR LARGER BUDGET
COMMITTEE. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO OUR CHAIR, TO OUR VICE CHAIR,
TO THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIRS, TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, BOTH DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN, FOR THEIR TENACITY
AND THEIR HARD WORK TO BE ABLE
TO GET THIS DOCUMENT DELIVERED
TODAY. AS PROMISED, I'M PROUD
THAT WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD A
BALANCED BUDGET, NOT JUST FOR
THE 2024 2025 FISCAL YEAR, BUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE DELIVER THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR AS WELL IN
2025, 2026. I'M NOT GOING TO BOG
MY BRIEF WORDS DOWN WITH THE
SLEW OF NUMBERS, BUT I WANT TO
FOCUS ON A FEW. CALIFORNIA HAS
SEEN RECORD FUNDING FOR K-12
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. WE'VE GONE FROM
DEAD LAST IN THE NATION IN 2015
TO NEARLY 24,000 PER STUDENT PER
YEAR THIS YEAR, AND WE'RE
FUNDING OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS WITH
AN ADDITIONAL $2 BILLION HIGHER
THAN WHAT THE MAY REVISION, THE
MAY REVISION WAS GOING TO
DELIVER. AND WE'RE RESTORING
FULL FUNDING FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOOLS PROGRAM BECAUSE WE
KNOW STUDENT DEBT IS DROWNING
THOUSANDS OF KIDS ACROSS THIS
STATE. WE'RE RESTORING NEARLY
11,000 CHILD CARE SLOTS AND
REJECTING CUTS TO CORE PROGRAMS
THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES RELY UPON, LIKE
CALWORKS FOSTER CARE AND IN-HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES. WE'RE KEEPING
CAL FIRE AND WILDFIRE FUNDING
WHOLE BECAUSE WE KNOW WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON WILDFIRE MITIGATION AND
RESPONSE. WE'RE PROVIDING $1
BILLION. $1 BILLION TO HELP
TACKLE OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN THIS STATE. AND OVER A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM, MAKING HOUSING
AFFORDABLE FOR WORKING FAMILIES.
WE ARE RESTORING CUTS TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAMS AND
VICTIM SUPPORT SERVICE PROGRAMS.
THIS IS RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING
AND PROTECTS THE PROGRESS THAT
WE HAVE ALL MADE TOGETHER OVER
THE PAST MANY YEARS. YOU KNOW,
IN THE PAST, OUR STATE'S BUDGET
PROCESS WORKED LIKE THIS. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BUDGET AND
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT, VETOED
IT, OR TOOK A BLUE PENCIL TO IT.
IN RECENT YEARS, WE HAVE BECOME
MORE ACCUSTOMED TO FINALIZING
THE BUDGET VIA THREE WAY
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN THE SENATE,
ASSEMBLY AND THE GOVERNOR.
THAT'S GREAT, AND I'LL BE
HONEST, WE'RE RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER FROM THIS HAPPENING. BUT
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS BUDGET
THAT WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD TODAY
WILL STAND ON ITS OWN, AND IT'S
WORTHY OF BEING CALIFORNIA'S
NEXT STATE BUDGET. AND HERE'S
WHAT I'LL SAY TODAY. WHAT WE
HAVE TODAY FOR THIS FRAMEWORK. I
FIRMLY BELIEVE YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE IN FRONT OF THIS BODY AND
THE ASSEMBLY NEXT WEEK AS WELL.
GIVEN OUR FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
THIS YEAR, WE PUT THE PIECES
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT GIVES US
THE BEST POSSIBLE FISCAL PICTURE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. WE HAVE
MADE SOME REALLY TOUGH, BUT
RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS THAT
PRESERVE FUNDING FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN THE
STATE, AND WE'RE INVESTING IN
SCHOOLS, HOUSING, WILDFIRE
PREVENTION, HEALTH CARE ACCESS,
PUBLIC SAFETY, CLIMATE IMPACTS,
AND DESPERATELY NEEDED RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN BIG CITIES AND SMALL.
IN EVERY CORNER OF THIS STATE, I
WANT TO DO A QUICK LOOK AHEAD.
FINAL BUDGET VOTES AS EARLY AS
NEXT WEEK. FINAL DISCUSSIONS.
THANKS TO THE HARD WORK OF OUR
BUDGET CHAIR AND OUR BUDGET SUB
CHAIRS, THEY'RE ADVANCING IN A
COLLABORATIVE MANNER, AND I WILL
CHARACTERIZE THEM AS EXTREMELY
PRODUCTIVE. AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THE FINAL BUDGET THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE IN FRONT OF US
HERE NEXT WEEK WILL FOLLOW THE
SAME FRAMEWORK THAT'S IN FRONT
OF THIS BODY HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU. TO THE CHAIR, TO MR. VICE
CHAIR, TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MR. PRESIDENT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR MCGUIRE
. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE RECOGNIZING SENATOR GROVE
FOR THE SECOND TIME, I APOLOGIZE
, MR. CHAIR. I WAS REALLY UPSET
ABOUT THE PRIORITIES, AND I
FORGOT TO SAY SOMETHING THAT I
NEED TO SAY, THIS IS THE FIRST
YEAR THAT I HAVE BEEN ON BUDGET
SUB THREE, WHERE WE, NO OFFENSE
TO PREVIOUS CHAIRS, HAVE HAD A
CHAIR THAT STOOD UP AND FOUGHT
FOR SERIOUSLY IN AGAINST AGAINST
THE GOVERNOR, AGAINST EVERYBODY
NOT TO HAVE CUTS FOR OUR
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS. THOSE ON, ON, YOU
KNOW, SNAP BENEFITS THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED IHSS
SERVICES, TO THE POINT WHERE I,
I WAS JUST SETTING OFF SOMETIMES
WITH BECAUSE SHE WAS GOING AFTER
HIM LIKE, WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
THAT? WHO DOES THAT? I MEAN, SHE
JUST REALLY WENT AFTER THEM TO
MAKE THEM RECANT OR TAKE BACK
THE CUTS, AND SO I JUST WANT TO
APPLAUD MY, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AS THE
BUDGET THREE CHAIR. AGAIN NO
OFFENSE AGAINST MY COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCKTON, WHO USED TO BE
THE BUDGET SUB THREE CHAIR, BUT,
THERE IS A MARINE IN CHARGE OF
BUDGET SUB THREE NOW, AND I AM
TOTALLY CONFIDENT THAT, OUR MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
WILL ALWAYS HAVE THE BENEFITS
THAT THEY NEED BECAUSE SHE IS IN
CHARGE OF THAT COMMITTEE. AND I
WAS JUST REALLY HONORED TO SERVE
ON THAT COMMITTEE WITH HER. AND
IN MY RANT EARLIER, OVER A HIGH
SPEED RAIL, I FAILED TO MENTION
THAT. WANTED TO MAKE SURE I DID
THAT, SIR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE MEMBERS, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
WIENER, YOU MAY CLOSE, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, THERE HAS
BEEN A LOT OF VERY DRAMATIC
RHETORIC TODAY, AND I'M NOT
GOING TO COMPLAIN ABOUT DRAMATIC
RHETORIC. THAT'S SOMETIMES PART
OF POLITICS. AND SO PEOPLE ARE
ENTITLED TO THEIR DRAMATIC
RHETORIC. WHAT I DO TAKE ISSUE
WITH IS WHEN THAT DRAMATIC
RHETORIC TRASHES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND DISMISSES ALL OF
THE GOOD IN THIS STATE AND ALL
THE GOOD THAT IS HAPPENING IN
THIS STATE, AND ALL THE GOOD
THAT IS IN THIS BUDGET. AND I
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WE'RE RESTORING THE FUNDING FOR
FOLKS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND THAT IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE ON A LIST OF
PRIORITIES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FULFILL, ALL IN THIS
BUDGET FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED OUR
HELP. AND SO I THERE IS SO MUCH
GOOD IN THIS STATE, AND I JUST
TAKE ISSUE WITH THE CONSTANT
TRASHING OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A BALANCED
BUDGET. THIS IS A RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET. AND I SAID THIS EARLIER
IN THE YEAR, AND I'M GOING TO
SAY IT AGAIN, WHEN WE HAD OUR
LAST REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR, WE HAD
NO BUDGET RESERVES. NONE. WE
WERE PAYING STATE WORKERS WITH
IOUS. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WAS PAYING WORKERS WITH IOUS
UNDER OUR LAST REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR. SINCE WE SHIFTED
ADMINISTRATIONS IN 2011, WE'VE
GONE FROM WE HAVE GONE TO OVER
$30 BILLION IN BUDGET RESERVES,
AND WE ARE PROTECTING THE BULK
OF THOSE RESERVES IN THIS
BUDGET. WE HAVE GONE FROM, AS
THE PRO TEM MENTIONED, SEVERELY
UNDERFUNDED K THROUGH 12 PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO DRAMATICALLY HIGHER
FUNDED. AND WE ARE PROTECTING
AND PRIORITIZING THAT FUNDING IN
THIS BUDGET. AND I'LL TELL YOU,
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT SUPPORTS
BUSINESSES AND SUPPORTS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN A STATE IN ANY
STATE, INCLUDING CALIFORNIA, IT
IS OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND WE
ARE SUPPORTING K THROUGH 12 AND
THE UC AND CSU, WHICH ARE
ABSOLUTE CROWN JEWELS. AND THE
BEST PUBLIC EDUCATION, PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS IN THE
COUNTRY. AND WE ARE PRIORITIZING
AND SUPPORTING THEM. IT IS CHILD
CARE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY
BOTH HAVE CHILDREN AND WORK.
THAT IS WHAT SUPPORTS OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR BUSINESSES. AND
WE HAVE PRIORITIZED CHILD CARE
IN THIS BUDGET. IT IS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE THAT SUPPORTS
BUSINESSES AND WHEN WE FORCE
IMMIGRANTS TO GET ALL OF THEIR
HEALTH CARE THROUGH THE
EMERGENCY ROOM, BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE WORKING AND
SUPPORTING OUR ECONOMY AND
PUTTING FOOD ON OUR TABLE AND
DOING ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
HARDWORKING IMMIGRANTS DO WHEN
WE FORCE THEM TO GET THEIR CARE
IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM. THAT IS
TERRIBLE FOR OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND FOR OUR ECONOMIES. I
AM PROUD THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND ALL OF OUR WORKERS WHO ARE
PAYING TAXES AND ARE
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF THIS
STATE. I AM, AND I WANT TO JUST
SAY IN TERMS OF HEALTH CARE
ALSO, I AM REALLY GLAD THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE APPEAR TO REALLY LIKE
MEDI-CAL. I PLEASE COMMUNICATE
TO YOUR TO YOUR PARTNERS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. TO STOP TRYING
TO DESTROY MEDICAID IN THIS
COUNTRY, BECAUSE THAT IS
HAPPENING AND WE NEED MEDI-CAL.
AND I'M PROUD OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO WITH THIS HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. FINALLY, I JUST WANT TO
SAY, IN TERMS OF OUR PRISON
SYSTEM, I WANT TO JUST NOTE THAT
IN 2013, CDCR'S BUDGET WAS $9.3
BILLION FOR A POPULATION THÀNH
IN PRISON OF 135,000 PEOPLE. IN
2324, IT'S 15 BILLION. IT'S GONE
UP BY OVER 50, BUT THE
POPULATION IS DOWN TO 92,000. SO
THE BUDGET GREW BY 60, WHILE THE
POPULATION DECREASED BY 30.
THAT'S A PROBLEM. AND SO BY
RIGHTSIZING THIS BUDGET, WE'RE
NOT UNDERMINING PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE'RE ACTUALLY RESPONSIVE
STEWARDING THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
AS WE DO ALL OF THE POLICY WORK
THAT WE ARE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO COMMIT RETAIL
THEFT ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. SO,
COLLEAGUES, THIS IS A
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET. IT REFLECTS
OUR VALUES. I AM PROUD OF THIS
STATE. AND YOU CAN CHERRY PICK
ABOUT THIS OR THAT COMPANY LEFT
THE NUMBER OF COMPANIES THAT ARE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
STARTING HERE, THAT ARE GROWING
HERE. COMPANY, A COMPANY LIKE
TESLA THAT NEVER ACTUALLY LEFT
AND KEPT ITS OPERATIONS HERE AND
IS NOW EXPANDING ITS OPERATIONS
HERE. I'M PROUD OF THIS ECONOMY,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ELLEN AYE. I'LL
RODA-GIL ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MEN NEWMAN. MAN I
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NÓ. NILO
NO. OKOBO. NO BADYOU. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. ON A VOTE OF 29 TO
8, THE MEASURE PASSES. AS
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE MAJORITY
LEADER, SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. WELL,
COLLEAGUES, TODAY WE HAVE THE
HONOR OF WELCOMING A
DISTINGUISHED DELEGATION FROM
THE JAPANESE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
JAPANESE BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO OUR
CHAMBER. THIS DELEGATION IS
COMPRISED OF 11 REPRESENTATIVES
FROM TWO ORGANIZATIONS,
INCLUDING MEMBERS OF THEIR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND
BUSINESS AND COMMERCE
COMMITTEES. LEADING THE GROUP
ARE KATSUHIRO GOMI, THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF NTT
RESEARCH, INC, THE GLOBAL R&D
ARM OF NIPPON TELEGRAPH AND
TELEPHONE CORPORATION, WHO IS
PRESIDENT OF THE JCC NC, AND
AKIRA MIYAMURA, THE PRESIDENT OF
KINTETSU ENTERPRISES COMPANY OF
AMERICA, WHO IS PRESIDENT OF THE
JBA. THEY ARE AT THE CAPITOL
TODAY IN ASSOCIATION WITH THE
RESPECTIVE ORGANIZATIONS. ONE'S
ANNUAL VISIT TO DISCUSS ISSUES
OF IMPORTANCE TO THE JAPANESE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY, AND
COLLECTIVELY, THEY REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY 750 MEMBER
BUSINESSES, AND THEY WORK TO
PROVIDE THEIR MEMBERS WITH A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF AMERICAN
CULTURE AND BUSINESS PRACTICES,
AND TO BUILD BRIDGES WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO IMPROVE JAPANESE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS. AND I WAS PLEASED
TO HAVE LED A DELEGATION OF OUR
MEMBERS TO JAPAN IN MARCH TO
LEARN ABOUT THE MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS OF JAPANESE
BUSINESSES TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. AND IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
EXTRAORDINARY, GIVEN THESE
STRONG ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
TIES IN THE FORM OF OVER 100,000
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP, AND THEY CERTAINLY
SAW A REALLY NICE DEBATE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE SENATE.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN WARM,
WELCOMING THESE DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE TODAY.
WELCOME TO THE SENATE.
RIGHT.
COULD I ASK MEMBERS TO RETURN TO
THEIR DESKS? WE HAVE MORE
BUSINESS TO CONDUCT. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THÀNH CHAU.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING FOR FILE ITEM 100.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 100. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1955 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1955 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD. AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE RIGHTS. MEMBERS, PLEASE
GIVE SENATOR EGGMAN YOUR
ATTENTION. SENATOR EGGMAN, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 1955 TO THE
STATE SENATE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AND ON
BEHALF OF THE LGBTQ CAUCUS,
PROBABLY SOME OF YOU REMEMBER AT
THE END OF LAST YEAR TOWARDS,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE ALL BEEN THROUGH
THE THROUGH COVID TOGETHER,
WE'VE ALL BEEN THROUGH STRIFE
TOGETHER, AND OVER THE LAST
YEAR, WE BEGIN TO SEE OUR, OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND OUR SCHOOL
BOARDS BECOME TURNED INTO,
THINGS THAT I WOULDN'T CALL
CIVICS. ONE OF THE EARLY BILLS I
DID WAS TO PROVIDE A SEAL OF
CIVICS FOR HIGH SCHOOL KIDS SO
WE COULD GET MORE PEOPLE
PREPARED TO BE ACTIVE CITIZENS
OF OUR SOCIETY AND LEARN TO
ENGAGE IN RESPECTFUL DEBATE. SO
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO, PUT SOME
GUARDRAILS ON THE FORCED OUTING
TYPE POLICIES THAT WERE
HAPPENING IN SCHOOL BOARDS. WE
KNOW SOME OF THOSE POLICIES HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO GO INTO EFFECT.
WE KNOW SOME OF THOSE SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS HAVE SINCE BEEN
RECALLED, AND THE LGBTQ CAUCUS
WANTED TO BE VERY CAREFUL AND
STRATEGIC AND SURGICAL ABOUT HOW
WE APPROACH THIS. WE DID NOT
WANT TO ADD TO THE TO THE
VITRIOL. WE DID NOT WANT TO ADD
TO THE, THE TEMPERATURE OR THE
VOLUME GOING UP ON SCHOOL
BOARDS. WHAT WE JUST WANT TO DO
IS MAKE SURE EVERYBODY IS SAFE
AT SCHOOL. WE WANT TO RETURN
SCHOOLS TO DO WHAT SCHOOLS ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO, AS IS, TEACH OUR
KIDS IS TEACH OUR KIDS AND
PROVIDE A SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY CAN FIGURE OUT WHO
THEY ARE. THAT IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR DEVELOPMENTAL TASKS THAT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US HAS TO DO
IS TO BEGIN TO SEPARATE FROM OUR
FAMILY OF ORIGIN AS WE GO OUT
INTO THE WORLD AND FIND OUR
PEOPLE. THAT IS PROBABLY THE
LARGEST DEVELOPMENTAL TASK ANY
ONE OF US CAN DO IS TO FIND OUR
COMMUNITY, FIND OUR PEOPLE, FIND
OUR SUPPORT, AND LEARN TO BE
HEALTHY PEOPLE IN THIS SOCIETY,
HEALTHY AND PRODUCTIVE PEOPLE.
SO WHEN WE SAW THE SEEMED LIKE
THE PROLIFERATION OF THESE
FORCED OUTING POLICIES WERE
LIKE, WHAT CAN WE DO? HOW CAN WE
APPROACH THIS? SO WE WORK WITH,
GROUPS ACROSS THE STATE. WE WORK
WITH PARENT GROUPS, TEACHER
GROUPS, ADMINISTRATOR GROUPS,
BOARD GROUPS, THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY ABOUT WHAT CAN WE DO?
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN WE SAW
THOSE SPECTACLES AT OUR SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS, WE KNOW WE SAW
THE IMPACT ON STUDENTS. WE KNOW
WE SAW THE NUMBER OF REFERRALS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH GO UP. WE KNOW
WE SAW THE AMOUNT OF BULLYING
AND HARASSING AND DIVISION BEGIN
TO INCREASE. AND WE THOUGHT, HOW
CAN WE TURN DOWN THE TEMPERATURE
ON SOME OF THIS AND JUST KIND
OF, YOU KNOW, LET'S SAY, HOW DO
WE GET BACK TO THE BASICS? HOW
DO WE GET BACK TO HOW IT WAS
WHEN WE WENT TO SCHOOL? WE WENT
TO SCHOOL TO LEARN. AND I CAN
TELL YOU, AS A AS A 63 YEAR OLD
PERSON, I BEGAN TO COME TO TERMS
WITH MYSELF WHEN I WAS PROBABLY
IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL, BEGAN TO
QUESTION MORE WHEN I WAS IN
EARLY HIGH SCHOOL. I BECAME
PRETTY SURE BY THE TIME I
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL, BUT
IT WAS NOT SOMETHING I SHARED
WITH MY PARENTS RIGHT AWAY. DID
I FEEL LIKE MY PARENTS WOULD
THROW ME OUT? NO, I DIDN'T, BUT
I KNEW IT WOULD BE. IT WOULD BE
HARD FOR THEM AND THEY WOULD
STRUGGLE WITH IT. AND YOU DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT TO YOUR PARENTS
UNTIL YOU'RE SURE AND WILL. I
KNEW MY PARENTS WOULD BE LOVING
AND SUPPORTIVE. I ALSO KNEW A
LOT OF OTHER PARENTS THAT
WEREN'T. AND LET ME JUST SAY,
THIS WAS IN THE 70S WHEN I WENT
TO HIGH SCHOOL RIGHT? 70S. SO IT
WAS A DIFFERENT TIME. AND I DO
REMEMBER WHEN I WAS STILL
EXPLORING AROUND, I WAS DATING A
GUY. THAT'S RIGHT. I WAS DATING
A GUY, AND THE SCHOOL CALLED MY
FAMILY. I REMEMBER MY DAD TAKING
ME FOR A RIDE AND HE SAID, DID
YOU KNOW? THE PRINCIPAL CALLED
ME, WHICH PUT FEAR IN SOMEBODY
LIKE SUSAN EGGMAN? I SAID, NO, I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT, DAD. AND HE
SAID, THE PRINCIPAL CALLED TO
TELL ME THAT YOU'RE DATING A
BLACK GUY. IS THAT TRUE? AND I
SAID, YEAH, IT IS. AND WHILE MY
PARENTS WERE NOT BIGOTS, IT WAS
ALSO THE 70S AND NOT SOMETHING
THAT THAT THEY WERE CELEBRATING.
BUT AT TO THIS DAY, I AM LEFT
WITH A THOUGHT OF, HOW DARE A
SCHOOL DISTRICT NOT KNOWING WHAT
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN TO ME AT
HOME, TAKE IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
SHARE SOMETHING PERSONAL ABOUT
ME THAT I HADN'T FELT
COMFORTABLE SHARING AT HOME. SO
WHY? WHY WOULD THE SCHOOL FEEL
COMPELLED TO DO THAT AND
INTERFERE WITH MY RELATIONSHIP
WITH MY PARENTS AND MY OWN
DEVELOPMENTAL PROCESS? I'M STILL
STRUCK BY THAT. AND STILL IT
MAKES ME ANGRY. SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS SIMPLY SAYS
SCHOOLS. YOU CANNOT SCHOOL
BOARDS CANNOT GET IN BETWEEN
STUDENTS AND THEIR PARENTS.
SCHOOLS SHOULD NOT BE INSERTING
THEMSELVES IN BETWEEN A CHILD'S
DEVELOPMENTAL PROCESS IN COMING
TO ADULTHOOD. THIS BILL SIMPLY
SAYS SCHOOLS CANNOT PASS
POLICIES THAT WOULD MANDATE
TEACHERS BECOME THE GENDER
POLICE FOR STUDENTS. THIS BILL
ALSO SAYS EDUCATION DEPARTMENTS
SHOULD PROVIDE INFORMATION FOR
ALL PARENTS ON LGBTQ ISSUES IF
THEY ARE, IF THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SEEK THINGS OUT BECAUSE
MAYBE SOMETIMES PARENTS DON'T
KNOW. THIS BILL ALSO SAYS IF A
THAT A TEACHER CANNOT BE
PENALIZED FOR REFUSING TO FOLLOW
A POLICY LIKE THAT, AND THIS
BILL ALSO AFFIRMS THAT STUDENTS
HAVE AN INNATE RIGHT TO PRIVACY,
UNLESS IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO HURT THEM, THAT WE ALL
HAVE AN INNATE RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
AND SO LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT DO, BECAUSE I
WATCHED THE ASSEMBLY HEARING AND
I WAS LEFT A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED
ABOUT WHAT SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS
WERE. BUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT DO, THIS BILL DOES NOT PUT
STUDENTS AT RISK. THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL WHICH
PREVENTS TEACHERS FROM GETTING
STUDENTS IN CRISIS THE HELP THEY
NEED. NOTHING CHANGES THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT KEEP SECRETS FROM
PARENTS. THERE IS NO WE DON'T
KNOW OF SECRETS THAT NEED TO BE
KEPT FROM PARENTS. THIS BILL
MANDATES THAT RESOURCES PROVIDE
TO SUPPORT FAMILIES IF THEIR KID
IS LGBTQ. PARENTS ARE ALWAYS
FREE TO HAVE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS AT HOME AS PARENTS
DO. ALL THIS DOES BASICALLY IS
SAY, SCHOOLS. IT'S NOT YOUR JOB
TO BE THE GENDER POLICE. WE
DON'T WANT THOSE POLICIES. WE
WANT EVERYBODY TO BE SAFE AND
AFFIRMED. WE DON'T WANT THIS
INCREASED PRESSURE IN SCHOOLS,
AND WE WANT KIDS TO BE ABLE TO
LEARN AND DEVELOP ON THEIR OWN
TIME. AND SO THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF SCARY STUFF ABOUT WHAT THIS
BILL IS, AND I HOPE I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO LEAVE SOME OF THOSE
DOUBTS AND JUST SAY, THIS BILL
IS ABOUT KEEPING ALL KIDS SAFE,
MAKING SURE SCHOOL BOARDS AREN'T
INSERTING POLICIES INTO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT MAKE POLICE KIDS,
TEACHERS, GENDER. POLICE CAN'T
PUNISH A TEACHER FOR NOT
POLICING KIDS AND KIDS HAVE A
RIGHT TO PRIVACY. THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU ALL
JOIN ME IN TURNING DOWN THE
VOLUME, TURNING UP, VALUING OUR
KIDS AND THEIR PROCESS. AND I'D
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR EGGMAN. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SENATOR NEWMAN? EXCUSE ME,
SENATOR DALI. AND THAT FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS, I RESPECT
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON
A LOT SO MUCH. I'M TAKING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT TACK TO THIS.
BILL, SHE ACTUALLY REACHED OUT
TO ME AND SHARED SHE WANTED TO
CHAT WITH ME. I GOT SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE BILL, BUT
I'M GOING TO I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT I THINK, NEEDS TO
HAPPEN HERE. I CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE OUT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, AND YOU'VE HEARD ME
MANY TIMES ON THIS FLOOR TALK
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL AND, AND I'M
NOT A BIG FAN OF THE STATE
TELLING LOCALS HOW TO RUN THEIR
COUNTY OR THEIR CITY OR THEIR
SCHOOL BOARDS, QUITE FRANKLY. SO
FOR ME, THIS IS ABOUT WHY WOULD
WE HAVE ELECTED SCHOOL BOARDS IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO TOP DOWN
POLICIES THAT TELL THEM WHAT
THEY CAN AND CAN'T DO? SO FOR
ME, IT'S A LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE,
PARENTS ARE ENGAGED IN THOSE
ELECTIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
THEY CHOOSE THEIR CANDIDATE AND
THEY GET BEHIND THOSE
CANDIDATES. AND SO FOR ME, I'M
GOING TO BE NOT SUPPORTING THIS
BILL BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THAT LOCAL CONTROL
THAT WE HAVE THOSE SCHOOL BOARDS
THAT MAKE THOSE DECISIONS. AND
THERE ARE CONFLICTS. ABSOLUTELY.
THERE ARE CONFLICTS. AND THOSE
SHOULD BE SETTLED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. AND I DO KNOW, IN MY
DISTRICT, THERE HAS BEEN SOME,
POLICY AROUND THIS AREA, NOT SO
MUCH AS MAYBE IN TEMECULA AND
SOME OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE.
BUT I DO HAVE, PARENTS WHO WHO
ARE ENGAGED AND SCHOOL BOARDS
WHO ARE ENGAGED. AND THERE ARE
SOME CONFLICTS THERE, BUT I
BELIEVE THEY'LL BE ABLE TO WORK
THOSE CONFLICTS OUT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WITHOUT OVERRIDING STATE,
COMING DOWN AND SAYING, HEY,
YOU'RE GOING TO DO THIS OR THAT.
I BELIEVE IN PARENTS AND SCHOOL
BOARDS, AND THAT'S WHY I WON'T
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DALI. I HAVE
SENATOR NEWMAN, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND SENATOR
WIENER. SENATOR NEWMAN, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. WE
HEARD THIS MEASURE IN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE EDUCATION. AND I
COMMEND TO YOU, MY COLLEAGUES
REMARKS ABOUT NOT ONLY WHAT THIS
BILL IS, BUT WHAT IT IS NOT. AND
IT IS, IN MY VIEW, WHOLLY
APPROPRIATE THAT THE STATE
SHOULD ARTICULATE AND DEFEND
SOME FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES,
ESPECIALLY IN THE DEFENSE OF A
VERY IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE THAT
SCHOOLS SHOULD BE A SAFE AND
NURTURING PLACE WHERE NO STUDENT
SHOULD BE AFRAID TO ATTEND
SCHOOL OR FEARFUL OF WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN IF WHAT HAPPENS AT SCHOOL
AND IN THE COURSE OF A NORMAL
DAY WINDS UP GOING HOME TO MY
SENATOR, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON'S COMMENTS, OR WINDS UP
IN THE NEWS AS PART OF THIS
INCREASINGLY FRACTIOUS, THIS
REALLY TOXIC CULTURE WAR
ARGUMENT THAT HAS COME TO SCHOOL
BOARDS AND OFTEN SEEMS, LIKELY
TO SUBSUME THE MORE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS, WHICH IS HOW DO
WE, AS A STATE PROVIDE THE BEST,
HIGHEST QUALITY, MOST EQUITABLE,
MOST NURTURING EDUCATION WE CAN?
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY, AND I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT IT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD SO FAR
AND ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON'S
REMARKS, MY DAUGHTER CAME OUT
WHEN SHE WAS PRETTY YOUNG,
CONSIDERING SHE WAS, WAS THE END
OF HER FRESHMAN YEAR IN HIGH
SCHOOL, AND BUT SHE DECIDED AND
IT WAS HER RIGHT TO MAKE THAT
DECISION TO NOT COME OUT TO ALL
OF HER FAMILY. AND AT THAT POINT
, HER FATHER AND I WERE NOT
TOGETHER. AND SHE DID NOT WANT
TO COME OUT YET TO HER FATHER.
AND I NEEDED TO RESPECT THAT.
AND IF WE HAD BEEN IN A
SITUATION WHERE THE SCHOOL WOULD
HAVE CALLED HER FATHER, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHAT A VIOLATION OF HER
PRIVACY AND WHAT A VIOLATION OF
HER ABILITY TO TALK TO HER
FATHER WHEN SHE WAS READY AND TO
WORK THAT OUT BETWEEN THEM,
WHICH, OF COURSE, THEY
EVENTUALLY DID. NOW,
ADDITIONALLY, SHE HAD MANY
FRIENDS WHO WERE NOT OUT, AND
THE STRESS ON THEM ABOUT THE
FEAR THAT THEY WOULD BE REJECTED
BY THEIR FAMILIES IF THEY CAME
OUT. I OBSERVED CAUSE REALLY
SEVERE SELF DESTRUCTIVE,
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH THOSE KIDS.
ONE OF THEM, WHO'S WHO WOULD
REGULARLY SPEND THE NIGHT AT OUR
HOUSE BECAUSE SHE FELT MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE, WOULD DO
SELF-MUTILATION. WE KNOW THAT
LGBTQ KIDS HAVE THE HIGHEST RATE
OF SUICIDE AND SUICIDE, AS WE
KNOW AMONGST OUR TEENS IS UP. WE
DO NOT WANT TO CONTRIBUTE TO
HIGHER RATES OF SUICIDE. IT IS
NOT. I REALLY APPRECIATE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY'S
COMMENTS ABOUT IT IS THE ROLE OF
OUR SCHOOLS TO HAVE OUR KIDS
FEEL SAFE AND AROUND THESE
THINGS THAT ARE PERSONAL TO THEM
, AND SOMETHING THEY NEED TO
WORK OUT WITH THEIR FAMILIES IS
SHOULD BE LEFT TO THEM. AND NOT
IMPOSED. AND I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON'S
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT HER
PRINCIPAL DID IN RELATIONSHIP TO
HER, YOU KNOW, DATING IS JUST
THE MOST PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHY
WE NEED THIS BILL AND WHY IT
SHOULD NOT JUST BE LEFT UP TO
EITHER LOCAL CONTROL OR THE
DISCRETION OF A PRINCIPAL WHO WE
DON'T KNOW WHOSE MOTIVE, WHAT
THEIR MOTIVATION MIGHT BE. SO I
APPRECIATE THIS, BILL. I
APPRECIATE OUR COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS, AND I URGE OUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR WIENER, I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 1955, AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVING THIS FORWARD, I HAD A, A
APROPOS OF WHAT? OF WHAT THE
SENATOR FROM STOCKTON JUST SAID.
I, I ADMITTED TO MYSELF THAT I
WAS GAY WHEN I WAS 17 YEARS OLD
IN THE LATE 1980S, I HAVE THE
MOST AMAZING PARENT PARENTS IN
THE WORLD WHO ARE, YOU KNOW, SO
SUPPORTIVE, SO, SO FORWARD
LOOKING AROUND LGBTQ ISSUES. I
LITERALLY HAVE A LESBIAN AUNT,
LESBIAN COUSIN WHO WERE OUT IN
THE 60S AND THE 70S, SO I HAD NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT MY PARENTS
WOULD BE COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE
AND AFFIRMING. IT STILL TOOK ME
THREE YEARS TO TELL
. REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU AS A
CHILD, YOU HAVE TO BE READY TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WITH YOUR
PARENTS. IT'S ALWAYS HARD, NO
MATTER HOW SUPPORTIVE THEY ARE.
AND THEY WERE AMAZING. BUT I
MADE THAT DECISION ON MY OWN
TIMETABLE WHEN I WHEN I WAS
READY, NOT WHEN SOMEONE ELSE WAS
READY TO TELL MY PARENTS. WHEN I
WAS READY TO TELL MY PARENTS.
AND FOR ANY LGBTQ PERSON,
WHETHER GAY, LESBIAN, TRANS, IT
IS THEIR BUSINESS AND THEIR
BUSINESS ONLY AND NO ONE ELSE'S
BUSINESS. WHEN WHETHER HOW THEY
TELL THEIR PARENTS. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE KIDS ARE
SAFE, AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE DOING IT ON THEIR
OWN TIMETABLE ABLE. AS HUMAN
BEINGS, I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER. I
HAVE MICROPHONES UP FROM SENATOR
NILO DURAZZO AND CIERTO SENATOR
NILO. THANK YOU. EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, I ALSO
HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON, NOT
JUST AS A COLLEAGUE IN THE
SENATE, BUT AS AN INDIVIDUAL
PERSON, WHICH SHE WILL BE AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR, I THINK. AND
STILL THE SAME PERSON. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER MENTIONED
THE ISSUE OF LOCAL CONTROL. I DO
THINK THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN THIS, BUT IT'S NOT THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IN MY MIND.
I UNDERSTAND HAD THE CHALLENGE
OF A MINOR GOING THROUGH
QUESTIONING OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION, OF GENDER DYSPHORIA
. VÀ, I CANNOT MINIMIZE THAT AT
ALL. THOUGH I DIDN'T EXPERIENCE
IT. I HEAR THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I FULLY
APPRECIATE THAT. AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF
STUDENTS. LEGITIMATELY BUT WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THE RIGHT
OF PARENTS. AND PARENTS DO HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY. Kò, IN
LISTENING TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO WITH WITH
UNDERSTANDING PARENTS, BUT HE
STILL DELAYED, AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT. I APPRECIATE THAT. I
HAPPEN TO FEEL THAT MOST PARENTS
ARE LIKE HIS PARENTS. THERE ARE
SOME THAT AREN'T. BUT TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT, WE'RE TREATING
NASA AS IF ALL OF THEM AREN'T.
AND I JUST ASKED THE QUESTION
NOT JUST FOR RELEVANT COLLEAGUES
IN THE ROOM, BUT FOR ANYBODY
ELSE THAT MIGHT BE WATCHING THIS
, SESSION OR THE PRESS THAT
MIGHT REPORT ON THIS SESSION. I
ASKED THE QUESTION, AS A PARENT
OR GRANDPARENT, BUT PRIMARILY
PARENT, HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF
YOUR CHILD CAME TO YOU TO
EXPRESS THEIR CONCLUSION
RELATIVE TO SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OR GENDER DYSPHORIA, NOT JUST
AFTER STRUGGLING WITH IT, HIS OR
HERSELF, BUT LEARNING THAT THE
KID HAD GONE THROUGH COUNSELING
WITH THE SCHOOL OR COUNSELING
UNBINNED IT TO THE PARENT AND
THE ISSUE BEING IN THE CHILD'S
MIND CONCLUDED AT THAT POINT,
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO STATED. NOW THIS BILL
IS GOING TO PASS. I GET IT, I'M
NOT GOING TO SUPPORT IT. BUT IT
WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT IT OUGHT
TO AT LEAST EXPRESS A PRIORITY
FOR THE SCHOOL TO TALK WITH THE
CHILD ABOUT COMMUNICATING WITH
HIS OR HER PARENTS. IT DOESN'T
SAY THAT WE I DO THINK WE HAVE
TO INCLUDE IN THE CONSIDERATION,
IN THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT
PARENTS HAVE AND THE RIGHTS OF
PARENTS TO IN THE WAY THAT I'VE
STATED. THANK YOU, SENATOR NILO.
SENATOR DURAZO, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR SATO AND SENATOR
MENGIBAR. SENATOR DURAZO. YES MY
REMARKS ARE VERY SHORT AND
SIMPLE. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR VERY MUCH. I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS, AND I WANT TO,
I WANT TO THANK MY GRANDSON FOR
HIS COURAGE AND FOR HIS STRENGTH
AND FOR HIS LOVE. SO THANK YOU,
SENATOR DURAZO. SENATOR CIERTO.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
THERE WE GO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SO I WANT TO START
OUT BY CLARIFYING AND MAKING
SURE THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON UNDERSTAND THAT I, I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU PUT INTO THIS. AND I WANT TO
GIVE YOU A PERSPECTIVE, AND I
HAVE TO STAND AND GIVE YOU THIS
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE I AM FROM
THE DISTRICT THAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT. I REPRESENT ALL
THREE OF THOSE DISTRICTS. AND SO
I UNDERSTAND. AND BUT THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PARENTS WHO
WANT TO BE PART OF A PROCESS AND
WANT SOLUTIONS THAT WORK FOR
THEM AND WANT TO BE INCLUDED IN
THEIR PARENTS, IN THEIR KIDS
LIVES. AND THAT'S, YOU KNOW, A
LOT OF THE PARENTS THAT I, I
REPRESENT ARE THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANT. THEY WANT TO BE INCLUDED.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. THEY WANT
TO KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
THEIR CHILD, BECAUSE WHEN THEY
DON'T, THEY GET A CHILD. THAT IS
ONE WAY AT HOME AND A DIFFERENT
WAY AT SCHOOL. THOSE ARE THE
KIDS THAT THEY WIND UP LOSING
AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHY. PARENTS
NEED TO BE PART OF THE PROCESS
AND I AM GLAD, AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT EXTENT THE PROCESS FOR
INCLUDING THOSE PARENTS IN THE
DISCUSSION OF A DEVELOPING THIS
BILL. BUT WHAT I NOTICED IN THIS
BILL IS, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WHEN A STUDENT GOES OFF TO
SCHOOL AND THEY MAY DRESS ONE
WAY WHEN THEY'RE LEAVING THE
HOUSE. AND, YOU KNOW, MY SISTER
DID THIS. SHE WAS NOT GAY OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, BUT SHE
DRESSED ONE WAY AT HOME AND THEN
WHEN SHE GOT SOMETIMES SHE TOOK
THE CLOTHES SHE WANTED TO WEAR
OUT OF THE BAG BECAUSE MY DAD
WOULDN'T LET HER OUT. WE WERE A
SINGLE PARENT FAMILY. WHEN? IN
THOSE YEARS, SO SHE WOULD CHANGE
WHEN SHE GOT TO SCHOOL. THIS IS
A LITTLE DIFFERENT, BUT WHEN
THAT HAPPENS, THEY'RE ALREADY
OUTED. THEY THEY'RE ALREADY OUT.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY DEALING WITH
IS WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE SO
THAT WE CAN SUPPORT THE CHILD,
BECAUSE THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS, IS
SUPPORTING THE CHILD AND
ENSURING BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THE SUPPORT THEY NEED AT
HOME AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
DO WELL WITH THE SCHOOL PART AND
SOME OF THOSE STATISTICS THAT
HAVE BEEN QUOTED OVER THE YEARS
ABOUT THIS OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS ABOUT THIS, INDICATE THAT
WIND UP HOMELESS. THEY WIND UP
WITHOUT AN EDUCATION BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT BEING SUPPORTED. AND
WE NEED TO FIND OUT SOONER THAN
LATER WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO
BE SUPPORTED OR NOT. SO AT THAT
POINT, WE CAN HELP SOMEHOW. NOW,
IS THIS A TEACHER'S
RESPONSIBILITY, NO. NO, MY WHOLE
FAMILY WERE TEACHERS, AND THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
LAY ON THEM BECAUSE GUESS WHAT?
THEY'RE NOT TRAINED FOR THAT
THEY ARE NOT TRAINED TO TRY TO
TAKE A POTENTIAL CONFLICT IN A
FAMILY AND MELED THAT FAMILY
BACK TOGETHER AGAIN AND, AND
WORK THEIR WAY THROUGH AN ISSUE
LIKE THIS. THAT'S WHAT PARENTS
ARE AFRAID OF. THEY DON'T WANT
TO BE LEFT OUT OF THAT
CONVERSATION. AND YES, SOME
PARENTS WON'T HANDLE IT WELL AND
SOME PARENTS MAY EVEN DO THE
REJECTION. AND THAT'S REALLY
SAD. I WENT THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL
THE SAME TIME THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM STOCKTON WENT THROUGH HIGH
SCHOOL, AND I HAD A LOT OF
REALLY FUNNY, GOOD FRIENDS THAT
WERE ATHLETIC, FUNNY, REALLY
SMART. AND YOU KNOW WHAT? SOME
OF THEM WERE GAY AND NONE OF US
CARED. AND THE SCHOOL DID NOT
CALL UP THEIR PARENTS. THE
PARENTS ALREADY KIND OF KNEW
THEY MAY HAVE NOT HAD THE
CONVERSATION, BUT THEIR PARENTS
KNEW. BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
THERE WAS THERE IS NO A LOT OF
NOT TRANSGENDERISM BACK THEN,
BUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT,
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE GOING INTO A
MEDICAL, A MEDICAL PART OF IT
THAT THAT REQUIRES ANY MINOR
THAT'S UNDER 18 TÍNH A PARENT TO
BE INVOLVED WITH THAT AND TO
ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T DO
SOMETHING THAT THE CHILD OR THEY
DON'T THE CHILD DOESN'T DO
SOMETHING THAT THEY WILL REGRET
LATER, AND MAYBE THEY WON'T.
THEY MAYBE THEY WON'T REGRET IT
LATER. WHEN I WAS RAISING MY
THREE DAUGHTERS, I HAD A RULE
YES, YOU COULD HAVE YOUR EARS
PIERCED ONCE AND YOU. BUT YOU
COULDN'T DO TATTOOS UNTIL YOU
WERE 18. THEN YOU COULD MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS. YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS 40, I DIDN'T
WANT THEM COMING TO ME AND
SAYING, DAD, WHY DID YOU LET
THIS HAPPEN TO ME? WE HAD TO BE
INVOLVED. WE WERE GREAT PARENTS
THAT WERE INVOLVED WITH OUR
KIDS. WE KNEW EVERY ASPECT THAT
WAS GOING ON. MOST OF THE TIME.
BUT WHEN THEY WERE IN DANGER,
YES, I DID GO TO NOT DANGER, BUT
WHEN THERE WERE CONFLICTS, I
ONCE GOT A CALL FROM A TEACHER
AT SCHOOL, AND I'M GLAD I DID
BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO INTERVENE,
WE TALKED TO DIFFERENT PARENTS
AND WE WERE ABLE TO REPAIR WHAT
WAS GOING ON. BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS, IF I DIDN'T KNOW, IT
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH, WITH
WITH THIS ISSUE, BUT IF I DIDN'T
KNOW, I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT. THAT'S
THE FRUSTRATION YOU ARE SEEING
AT THESE BOARDS. BOARD MEETINGS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT. AND THAT'S
WHAT SOME OF THAT LEGISLATION OR
SOME OF THE BOARD ACTIONS ARE
BUILT AROUND THAT FRUSTRATION
AND TRYING TO DEFUZE IT BECAUSE
THE LOUDEST PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
ARE DOING THAT. WE NEED TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION. WE NEED
SOLUTIONS THAT INCLUDE PARENTS,
NOT NOT TEACHERS, THAT TEACHERS
AREN'T THE NOTIFICATION PROCESS.
BUT WHEN THIS ARISES UP, WHEN
THIS RISES UP IN SOMEBODY'S LIFE
, THEY'RE ALREADY OUT. THEY'RE
GOING TO FIND OUT SOCIAL MEDIA,
ALL THE INFORMAL LINES OF
COMMUNICATION WILL ENSURE THAT
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO HEAR ABOUT
IT IN AN UNCONTROLLED MANNER.
WHEN THIS HAPPENS, WHAT WE
SHOULD DO IS DEVELOP A PROCESS
WHERE WE DO HAVE A FAMILY
COUNSELOR THAT'S ABLE TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE STUDENT. WE'RE
ABLE TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
PARENTS AND SAY, THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING ON, HOW ARE WE GOING TO
HANDLE THIS? THAT WAY WE KNOW
WHICH PARENTS HANDLE IT WELL AND
WHICH PARENTS DON'T. AND THAT
WAY WE CAN OFFER THE TYPE OF
HELP FOR THESE STUDENTS THAT
THEY NEED. I'M AFRAID WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT JUST POKES
ANOTHER STICK IN THE EYE OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT, AND FURTHER CEMENTS THE
IDEOLOGICAL DIVIDE. AND THAT'S
MY CONCERN WITH THIS. IF WE
INCLUDE THE PARENTS, THAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO TAKE SOMETHING FROM
PEOPLE BEING ANGRY AND MAD TO
DEVELOPING A SOLUTION THAT WORKS
FOR EVERYBODY. AND THIS DOESN'T
QUITE GET THERE. SO
UNFORTUNATELY, I WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS PARENTAL
RIGHTS ARE SUPER IMPORTANT, AND
IF WE DON'T, IF WE KEEP IGNORING
THAT, IT'S GOING TO KEEP BEING A
BIGGER AND BIGGER ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR SUGIARTO
. LET'S RECOGNIZE NOW, SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO SHARE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE TO WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM TWO OF MY
LGBTQ PLUS CAUCUS MEMBERS. WHAT
MY PARENT, MY MOM, THOUGHT WAS
HER RESPONSIBILITY WHEN I WAS
OUTED TO HER AT 16 YEARS OLD, I
WAS IN A HIGH SCHOOL THAT WAS
SAFE AND AFFIRMING TO ME. I FELT
VERY TRUE TO MYSELF WHERE I WAS
ABLE TO BE WITH MY OTHER QUEER
FRIENDS. BUT THE BOYFRIEND OF MY
COUSIN OUTED ME. HE TOLD MY
COUSIN, WHO WAS AT A DIFFERENT
SCHOOL, WHO THEN TOLD MY AUNT,
WHO TOLD MY MOM. I CAME HOME TO
LITERALLY ALL MY THINGS ON THE
FRONT LAWN. BECAUSE I WAS KICKED
OUT. THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
PARENTS DON'T ACCEPT QUEER KIDS.
OKAY YOU CAN HAVE ALL THESE
POSITIVE STORIES, BUT THERE ARE
MORE THAN ENOUGH STORIES. JUST
LIKE MINE. I WENT BACK INTO THE
CLOSET BECAUSE I NEEDED A PLACE
TO SLEEP, BECAUSE I NEEDED A
ROOF OVER MY HEAD TO CONTINUE
HIGH SCHOOL. SO I HID MYSELF AND
I TOLD MY MOM IT WAS JUST A FACE
. AND THEN I STARTED DATING A
BOY AND I WOULD BRING HIM HOME
SO MY MOM WOULD SEE THAT I WAS
IN FACT JUST CONFUSED AND LOST.
SO I LOST MY ROOM, MY BIG ROOM,
BECAUSE I WAS AN A STUDENT, I
WAS AN ATHLETE. I HAD MY OWN
BATHROOM IN MY ROOM, AND SHE PUT
ME IN THE SMALLEST ROOM. AND
THIS WAS RIGHT BEFORE WE GOT
EVICTED FROM OUR HOME. I DIDN'T
COME OUT TO MY MOM UNTIL THE AGE
OF 25. AFTER THAT. AND THEN SHE
SAID MY LIFE WAS LIKE A
PROSTITUTE. TILL THIS DAY, MY
MOM DOESN'T ACCEPT ME. ENDLESS
AMOUNT OF CONVERSATIONS. YOU
WANT TO TALK TO COUNSELORS? NO
AMOUNT OF COUNSELORS ARE GOING
TO CHANGE CERTAIN PARENTS
PERSPECTIVES OF THEIR PARENTS,
OF THEIR KIDS WHO ARE QUEER. MY
FRIEND WOULD SPEND ENDLESS
AMOUNT OF HOURS CRYING IN MY CAR
BECAUSE HER MOM DID NOT ACCEPT
HER AT 23, AT 24, AND TO THIS
DAY, WE TRAUMA BOND ABOUT HOW WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE TO KIND OF CODE
SWITCH WHENEVER WE'RE WITH OUR
MOM. I'M 35 YEARS OLD AND I
REPRESENT 1 MILLION PEOPLE, AND
I HAVE TO STILL CODE SWITCH WHEN
I'M WITH MY MOM FOR SAFETY
REASONS, BOTH MENTALLY AND MAYBE
PHYSICALLY. AND THERE ARE MANY
QUEER KIDS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
HAVE THESE STORIES, WHO GO TO
SCHOOL AND FEEL SAFE. THEY CAN
BE THEIR TRUE SELVES. THEY CAN
WEAR WHATEVER THEY WANT, AND
THEN THEY HAVE TO CODE SWITCH AT
HOME. BUT UNTIL THEY'RE 18 YEARS
OLD, WE ARE ASKING FOR 18 YEARS
OF THEIR LIFE TO NOT HAVE TO
CODE SWITCH AT SCHOOLS TO BE
SAFE, AND KNOW THAT NO ONE IN
THAT ESTABLISHMENT WILL HELP
THEM UNTIL THEY ARE READY. AND
WE DO THIS BECAUSE WE KNOW OUR
PARENTS. I KNEW MY MOM HOW SHE
WAS GOING TO REACT. I WENT TO
SCHOOL, I WENT TO CHURCH,
PENTECOSTAL CHURCH. YOU CAN
IMAGINE I KNEW HER
UNDERSTANDING. THE PASTOR SPOKE
ABOUT HOMOSEXUALITY EVERY SINGLE
SUNDAY, FRIDAY NIGHT, WEDNESDAY,
THREE TIMES A WEEK I WOULD GO TO
CHURCH. I KNEW HOW MY MOM WAS
GOING TO ACT. I DID THIS BECAUSE
I KNEW THESE KIDS, IF THEY FEEL
SAFE WITH THEIR PARENTS, WE'LL
TALK TO THEIR PARENTS. CGRTS IF
WE DO NOT FEEL SAFE, LET US
NAVIGATE THAT UNTIL WE ARE READY
OR UNTIL WE DON'T HAVE TO LIVE
WITH THEM OR UNTIL WE DON'T
DEPEND ON THEM FOR A ROOF OVER
OUR HEADS. SO THIS BILL IS
NEEDED TO PROTECT US SO THAT
THERE'S NO BARRIERS LIKE THIS.
AND SO A LITTLE 16 YEAR OLD
QUEER KID WHO ALMOST LOST HER
HOME CAN GROW UP AND BE A STATE
SENATOR. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVO. SENATOR LAIRD, SENATOR
RUBIO, FOLLOWED BY SENATOR LAIRD
, SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, YOU
KNOW, I THINK THAT THIS BILL,
YOU KNOW, I HEAR EVERYONE'S
CONCERNS, YOU KNOW, AND AT THE
HEART OF IT, I YOU KNOW, I DO
BELIEVE IN PARENTS RIGHTS. AND I
THINK THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING TO TAKE PARENTS RIGHTS
AWAY. I THINK THAT PARENTS STILL
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DISCUSS
ANYTHING THEY WANT WITH THEIR
CHILDREN. I STILL THINK THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO INQUIRE, SET
THE TABLE SO THAT THEIR CHILDREN
FEEL SAFE TO COME FORWARD AND
SPEAK TO THEM WHEN THEY'RE
THEY'RE FEELING CONFUSED. IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU KNOW THEY CHOOSE
TO DO. BUT I ALSO KNOW AS A
TEACHER SO MUCH THAT TEACHERS
HAVE TO TAKE ON. AND THIS JUST
SIMPLY SAYS IT'S NOT ONE MORE
THING THAT TEACHERS HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT. THAT IS NOT THEIR
JOB. THEIR JOB IS TO INQUIRE
ABOUT THEIR LEARNING,
DEFICIENCIES. HOW DO WE HELP
THEM BE SUCCESSFUL? WHAT DO THEY
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL WORLD? BUT AGAIN,
WHEN IT COMES TO PARENTS RIGHTS,
THEY STILL HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
INQUIRE, QUESTION, SIT DOWN WITH
THEM. I THINK THAT'S STILL GOING
TO BE THERE REGARDLESS OF THIS
BILL. AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE I
KEEP HEARING THE CONFUSION. THIS
DOES NOT TAKE ANY RIGHTS AWAY.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT,
AND I'M SO GLAD THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FERNANDO
HIGHLIGHTED A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE. I'M GOING TO ADD
ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE. YOU KNOW,
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT I AM A
VICTIM'S RIGHTS ADVOCATE. I'VE
BEEN FIGHTING FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS. AND I HAVE
TO TELL YOU, I KEEP HEARING OVER
AND OVER AGAIN LET PARENTS DEAL
WITH THIS. IF ONLY ALL PARENTS
DID THE RIGHT THING. IF ONLY
THEY OPEN THEIR ARMS AND EMBRACE
THEIR CHILDREN. SO I'M GOING TO
GIVE YOU JUST TWO EXAMPLES OF
HOW THAT IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
AND I THINK CHILDREN ARE WORTH
SAVING. ONE, AS I'M NAVIGATING,
YOU KNOW, BEING A VICTIM'S
ADVOCATE, I'M ALWAYS LISTENING
TO THESE STORIES AND I'LL JUST
TELL YOU A STORY OF A FIVE
LITTLE FIVE YEAR OLD LITTLE GIRL
WHO WHOSE MOTHER, AT THE AGE OF
FIVE, WAS PASSING HER AROUND TO
MEN FROM FIVE ALL THE WAY TO 15.
THIS LITTLE GIRL WAS ABUSED,
ASSAULTED, SÐNG OLD, FIVE YEARS
OLD. IF ONLY PARENTS ALWAYS DID
THE RIGHT THING. THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE. I WAS A VICE
PRINCIPAL IN AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL WHEN A LITTLE GIRL TOLD
ME THAT SHE WAS BEING RAPED BY
HER STEPFATHER, IT WAS MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO CALL CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES. AND LATER ON,
I LEARNED THAT SHE WAS STILL IN
THE HOME. AND WHEN I STARTED
INQUIRING ABOUT WHY SHE WAS
DOING THE HOME, IT APPEARED THAT
THE LITTLE GIRL RECANTED BECAUSE
THE MOTHER DIDN'T WANT TO LOSE
HER BOYFRIEND, SO SHE RATHER
HAVE HER LITTLE GIRL BEING
ASSAULTED AND RAPED EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT. RATHER THAN LOSE HER
BOYFRIEND AGAIN. IF ONLY PARENTS
ALWAYS DID THE RIGHT THING. THAT
IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE, AND I
AGREE THAT THERE'S A FEW PEOPLE
THAT ARE BAD ACTORS AND NOT ALL
PARENTS ARE BAD. BUT AGAIN, IT
IS UP TO PARENTS PARENTS RIGHTS
TO SIT DOWN WITH THEIR CHILDREN
AND SET THE TABLE AND SAY WE'RE
HERE. WHATEVER IT IS. NOT
NECESSARILY ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
ANYTHING GANGS, DRUGS, ANYTHING
THAT YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT. WE
ARE HERE FOR YOU. YES. SO
PARENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DEVELOP THAT RELATIONSHIP. SO
WHEN SOMETHING GOES WRONG, AGAIN
, NOT NECESSARILY ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. IT COULD BE ANYTHING THEY
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT IF THEY WENT
TO THEIR PARENTS, THEY'RE GOING
TO BE RESPECTED AND LISTENED TO.
SO AGAIN, I WANT TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT NOT ALL
PARENTS DO THE RIGHT THING.
UNFORTUNATELY, I WISH THEY DID.
THEY JUST DON'T. AND AS A
TEACHER, I CAN TELL YOU WE SPEND
A LOT OF TIME TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT YOUR CHILDREN HAVE A GOOD
EDUCATION. WE DON'T NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ADD MORE THINGS THAT
DON'T BELONG IN THE CLASSROOM.
OUR JOB IS TO TEACH OUR JOBS TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR CHILDREN ARE
SUCCESSFUL. OUR JOB IS TO TELL
YOU WHERE THE DEFICIENCIES ARE,
WHAT YOU NEED TO HELP YOUR CHILD
SUCCEED, WHAT AREAS YOU NEED TO
FOCUS ON. WE DON'T NEED TO GET
INTO YOUR BUSINESS, YOUR LIFE,
YOUR YOUR HOME. WE ARE THERE
JUST TO TEACH AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR CHILDREN ARE SAFE. AND I
CAN REMEMBER MANY TIMES CHILDREN
WOULD COME TO ME AND IT WASN'T
BECAUSE THEY CAME TO ME, BECAUSE
I WAS THE RIGHT PERSON TO TELL.
THEY TOLD ME BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE ANYBODY TO TELL AT HOME.
THEY DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO BE SAFE. IF THEY
SAID SOMETHING AT HOME. SO LET'S
JUST REMEMBER THAT NOT ALL
PARENTS DO THE RIGHT THING. AND
I'M SPEAKING FOR THAT FIVE YEAR
OLD LITTLE GIRL WHO HAD TO
ENDURE TORTURE BECAUSE HER
MOTHER PASSED HER AROUND AT THE
AGE OF FIVE TO DEFEND MEN. AND
LET'S ALSO REMEMBER GABRIEL
FERNANDEZ, IF YOU DON'T REMEMBER
THAT CASE, HIS MURDER, HIS
TORTURE, HIS DEATH WAS BASED ON
RUMORS THAT HE MIGHT BE GAY AND
THE PARENTS TORTURED HIM MORE,
MURDERED HIM. AND THE SAD PART
ABOUT THAT CASE IS THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT DIDN'T KNOW ADULTS
DIDN'T KNOW ADULTS SAW THE
BRUISES, THE HARM. THEY SHAVED
HIS HEAD. HE HAD BUMPS. I MEAN,
ALL THE SIGNS WERE THERE. AND
YET PARENTS NOT ONLY DID NOT DO
THE RIGHT THING, THEY WERE THE
ONES INFLICTING THE PAIN ON POOR
GABRIEL FERNANDEZ. SO I WILL
JUST ADD THAT THIS BILL JUST
KEEPS CHILDREN SAFE. AND WITH
THAT I ALSO ASK FOR AN EYEBALL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO. I HAVE MICROPHONES UP
FROM SENATOR LEONARD PADILLA AND
ATKINS. SENATOR LEONARD. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I HAD PUT MY
MICROPHONE DOWN BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THE SPEECH BY THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FERNANDO MADE
THE CASE IN A WAY THAT I
COULDN'T SEE ANYBODY ADDING TO
IT. BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO PUT THAT SPEECH IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS DEBATE, BECAUSE
IT WAS SAID EARLIER, AND I'M NOT
GOING TO GET IT EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT BASICALLY THAT THIS BILL
ISN'T ABOUT THE MAJORITY OF KIDS
. THAT'S RIGHT. IT'S ABOUT THE
KIDS LIKE THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FERNANDO. AND WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEM, REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY'RE IN THE MAJORITY OF ALL
KIDS. AND IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US
TO PROTECT THOSE KIDS. AND I
ALWAYS REFER I WISH I HAD A COPY
OF IT WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THERE WAS A STUDY DONE
BY SAN FRANCISCO STATE WHERE
THEY INTERVIEWED, GAY KIDS ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM WHEN THEY
CAME OUT, AND EVENTUALLY THEY
CIRCLED BACK TO THE PARENTS AND
INTERVIEWED THEM. AND THERE WAS
A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF KIDS
THAT WERE THROWN OUT OF THE
HOUSE WHEN IT BECAME CLEAR. AND
THEY JUST MOVED INTO MANY OF
THEM, AN UNSPEAKABLE LIFE ON THE
STREETS, HORRIBLE THINGS AT RISK
IN MAJOR WAYS AND THAT STUDY
ACTUALLY CIRCLED BACK TO THE
PARENTS AND MANY PARENTS, WHEN
CONFRONTED WITH THE FACT THAT
THE CHOICE WAS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TO THEIR KIDS ON THE
STREET AS A RESULT OF THEM
THROWING THEM OUT, THEY REALLY
VÆ MANY OF THEM CHANGED THEIR
VIEW ABOUT THE SAFETY OF THEIR
KIDS, BUT IN MANY CASES WAS IT
WAS TOO LATE. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT. IT IS AND I
RECALL WHEN I WAS A KID, MY
FATHER WAS ONE OF THOSE TEACHERS
THAT EVERYBODY CAME AND TALKED
TO, AND HE MIGHT ADVISE PEOPLE
TO GO TALK TO THEIR PARENTS, BUT
HE WAS TRYING TO HAVE THEM HAVE
A PLACE WHERE THEY COULD FEEL
SAFE AND A VOICE AND ACKNOWLEDGE
WHO THEY WERE, AND WORK THROUGH
WHAT THE ISSUES WERE IN A WAY
THAT THEY WEREN'T PUT AT THAT
KIND OF RISK. AND IT HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT TO HEAR THAT THIS IS A
MATTER OF LOCAL CONTROL, BECAUSE
I IMAGINE IF YOU'RE AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND WE'RE IN THE SOUTH
FOR THE 100 YEARS AFTER THE
CIVIL WAR, YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT
LOCAL CONTROL MEANT. IT WAS
CALLED STATE RIGHTS, BUT IT
REALLY MEANT YOU COULDN'T VOTE.
YOU COULDN'T HAVE EQUAL
FACILITIES. YOU WERE AT THE RISK
OF BEING LYNCHED. AND WE AS A
PEOPLE FELT LIKE THERE WAS A
HIGHER, CALLING AND A HIGHER
CIVIL RIGHT TO ACT IN UNISON TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE PROTECTED
THOSE PEOPLE THAT WERE NOT IN
THE MAJORITY. AND IT WAS NOT
ABOUT, WELL, IT WAS ABOUT THE
MAJORITY, BECAUSE IT WAS ABOUT
WHAT THE MAJORITY WAS DOING TO
THE MINORITY. BUT IN ESSENCE,
THAT ALL THESE ISSUES ARE WHAT
WE FACE HERE, TO PROTECT THE
KIDS, REGARDLESS OF WHEN THEY'RE
WHETHER THEY'RE IN THE MAJORITY
TO OVERRIDE DODD, PEOPLE THAT
MIGHT NOT HAVE THAT BEST
INTEREST. AND TO JUST REMEMBER
THE SPEECH THAT WAS GIVEN BY THE
SENATOR OF STANFORD FROM SAN
FERNANDO, BECAUSE THAT'S WHY WE
SHOULD ALL VOTE FOR AB 1955.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD.
SENATOR PADILLA, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES AND MY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES, THANK YOU
FOR SOME AMAZING TESTIMONIALS,
OF COURSE, I RISE IN SUPPORT,
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER MAYBE AN UNCOMFORTABLE
TRUTH. FOR SOME, THIS IS NOT
ABOUT PARENT'S RIGHTS. THIS IS
ABOUT RETURNING TEACHERS TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY ARE FOCUSED. ON
PROVIDING QUALITY EDUCATION AND
A NURTURING, SAFE AND HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL CHILDREN, NO
MATTER THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES. IT
IS REALLY AN EDUCATIONAL
HIPPOCRATIC OATH. DO NO HARM
EITHER. INTENTIONALLY OR
UNWITTINGLY. WHEN I WAS A VERY
SMALL BOY IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL,
I HAD A PRETTY PRONOUNCED SPEECH
LISP, SOMETHING THAT
UNFORTUNATELY, IN OUR CULTURE
AND SOCIETY FOR MANY GENERATIONS
, WE STEREOTYPED AND WERE
DERISIVE AND HOSTILE TOWARDS AS
A STEREOTYPE OF YOUNG GAY BOYS
AND MEN. THERE WAS A PERIOD OF
TIME WHEN I WAS IN THIRD AND
FOURTH GRADE, WHERE LITERALLY
EVERY SINGLE DAY, THE SAME GROUP
OF BOYS, BECAUSE THESE WERE THE
DAYS, OF COURSE, WHEN KIDS COULD
WALK HOME 4 OR 5 BLOCKS
UNACCOMPANIED AND IT WASN'T A
PROBLEM, BUT I WOULD GET JUMPED
AND BEAT UP ALMOST EVERY DAY ON
THE WAY HOME FROM SCHOOL, I
WOULD COME HOME WITH TORN
CLOTHING AND SOME BRUISES, TO
THE POINT THAT IT ALARMED MY
MOTHER SO MUCH. NOT JUST THE
PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL INJURY,
BUT OF COURSE, THE FACT THAT SHE
WOULD CONTINUALLY HAVE TO KEEP
SHOPPING FOR A NEW SET OF SCHOOL
CLOTHES. WE ENDED UP IN THE
PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE WITH MY
MOTHER HOLDING SOME OF MY TORN
SHIRTS IN HER HAND AND DEMANDING
THAT THE SCHOOL DO SOMETHING TO
INTERVENE EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME, I TRIED WALKING
DIFFERENT WAYS, DIFFERENT BLOCKS
. I TRIED SLIPPING AWAY, STAYING
LATE, BUT THERE WERE SOME FOLKS
THAT JUST DIDN'T APPRECIATE HOW
I EXPRESSED MYSELF AND JUMPED TO
CONCLUSIONS ABOUT WHAT THAT
MEANT. I KNEW THAT I WAS
DIFFERENT AND DECIDED, FOR
WHATEVER REASONS, THEY PROBABLY
LEARNED AT HOME OR GLEANED FROM
THE IMPLICATIONS AND DIALOG OF
EVERYDAY CONVERSATIONS. ALL THE
THINGS ON THE PLAYGROUND. I
WON'T REPEAT THE NAMES, THE
WORDS EVERY DAY THAT IT WAS
WORTH PUTTING A LITTLE ENERGY
INTO. FOLLOWING STEVE PADILLA
HOME NO MATTER WHICH WAY HE
CHOSE TO WALK. A FEW YEARS AGO,
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY AS AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL TO ADDRESS A
CONVENING IN CHULA VISTA AT EAST
LAKE HIGH SCHOOL OF THE GAY
STRAIGHT ALLIANCE. THIS WAS 400
PEOPLE IN AN AUDITORIUM OF ALL
THE GAY STRAIGHT ALLIANCE CLUBS
IN THE DISTRICT. AND WHAT I
WOULD HAVE GIVEN, WHAT I WOULD
HAVE GIVEN TO HAVE SUCH A THING
AS A BOY. AND I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT IT HAD BEEN LIKE THOSE
DAYS, WALKING HOME AND COMING
HOME WITH TORN CLOTHING. IF, ON
TOP OF THE TREATMENT FROM MY
FELLOW STUDENTS, I HAD TO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT MY PARENTS MIGHT DO
FOR WHATEVER REASON, CULTURAL,
SOCIAL, RELIGIOUS OR OTHERWISE,
AND WHEN I SPOKE TO THIS GROUP
OF GSA STUDENTS, I WAS HONORED
TO SPEAK ALONGSIDE SOME PULSE
NIGHTCLUB SURVIVORS FROM ORLANDO
. AND I WAS ABLE TO TELL MY OWN
STORY AND MY JOURNEY TO HUNDREDS
OF STUDENTS. AND WHEN WE WERE
DONE, I WAS LEAVING WITH MY
STAFF. AND I WILL NEVER FORGET
THESE TWO JUNIORS, TWO YOUNG
LATINA GIRLS CAME UP TO ME ARM
IN ARM. AND ONE OF THE GIRLS WAS
JUST WEEPING WITH TEARS COMING
DOWN HER FACE DIDN'T SAY A WORD.
SHE WAS IN BILINGUAL IMMERSION.
HER FRIEND WAS VERY FLUENT AND
SHE JUST WALKED UP TO ME AND HER
FRIEND WAS LITERALLY BAWLING.
SHE SAID, MY FRIEND WANTS TO
MEET YOU. SHE DIDN'T SAY A WORD.
SHE JUST CRIED. AND I WILL NEVER
FORGET THINKING TO MYSELF, WHAT
MUST THIS CHILD BE DEALING WITH
EVERY DAY THAT NOT ONLY AFFECTS
HER AS A HUMAN BEING, BUT
CERTAINLY INTERRUPTS THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT SHE DESERVED TO
LEARN THIS IS NOT ABOUT PARENT
RIGHTS. THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING
THE DIGNITY AND WORTH OF EVERY
STUDENT AND ACKNOWLEDGING THE
LONG UNDERSTOOD REALITY THAT
THERE ARE SITUATIONS IN WHICH,
INTENTIONALLY OR UNWITTINGLY, WE
CAN PLACE STUDENTS IN DANGER AND
WE OUGHT NOT TO DO THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR PADILLA.
SENATOR ATKINS, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL. CERTAINLY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON AND
THE LGBTQ PLUS CAUCUS FOR DOING
THIS AND BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I HAVE APPRECIATED HEARING THE
STORIES OF PARENTS, OF
GRANDPARENTS, OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE HAD STORIES. WE ALL
HAVE STORIES THAT BRING US TO
THIS MOMENT, PARTICULARLY MY
COLLEAGUE, FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. I COULD HAVE HAD A
SIMILAR STORY. I WAS AFRAID OF
ABANDONMENT AND REJECTION, SO I
DIDN'T COME OUT TO MY PARENTS
UNTIL I WAS IN COLLEGE, AND I
KNEW I HAD A BED TO SLEEP IN AND
A PLACE TO BE. NOW. MY PARENTS
HAD A DIFFERENT REACTION, AND
I'M GRATEFUL. I AM SO GRATEFUL.
BUT I JUST STOOD UP BECAUSE I
WANTED TO ADD MY VOICE OF
APPRECIATION TO TEACHERS BECAUSE
WHEN I WAS AFRAID OF ABANDONMENT
AND REJECTION AND DIDN'T COME
OUT TO MY PARENTS WHEN I WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL, THERE WAS A TEACHER
THERE. AND I NEVER TALKED TO ONE
OF THOSE TEACHERS IN HIGH SCHOOL
ABOUT THE FACT THAT I MIGHT BE A
MEMBER OF THE GAY COMMUNITY, I
NEVER HAD TO DO THAT, BUT I
COULD ALWAYS FEEL THE SUPPORT OF
TEACHERS. AND I KNOW THAT ALL OF
US CAN THINK OF ONE TEACHER THAT
MADE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR LIVES,
AND WE CAN SAY THEIR NAMES EVEN
TODAY. AND SO MY VOICE, RIGHT
NOW IS APPRECIATION FOR ALL OF
YOUR STORIES AND YOUR
PERSPECTIVES TO HAVE THIS
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION. BUT
TODAY, THE SUPPORT, AS A NUMBER
OF COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID, FOR
TOOLS FOR TEACHERS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEIR KIDS, WHATEVER
THOSE ISSUES ARE, I REMEMBER A
TEACHER GIVEN $2 TO ONE OF THE
KIDS AND TELLING HIM HOW TO GO
TO THE LAUNDROMAT AND WASH HIS
CLOTHES, AND I RAN INTO THE KID
AT THE LAUNDROMAT AND HE TOLD ME
I WAS A FEW YEARS OLDER THAN
HIM, BUT HE TOLD ME WHICH
TEACHER, MISS CLAYTOR, WHO I HAD
HAD IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL, GAVE
HIM $2 SO HE COULD GO DO HIS
LAUNDRY IN A LAUNDROMAT BECAUSE
THE KID DID. I MEAN, I DON'T
THAT KID THAT WAS ABOUT A KID
WHO OBVIOUSLY HAD ISSUES. SO
THIS BILL TODAY IS REALLY
SUPPORT FOR KIDS. YES. BUT IT'S
ALSO SUPPORT FOR THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO TEACH KIDS AND TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE KIDS IN
THEIR EVERYDAY LIFE. AND SO I
WANTED TO GIVE VOICE TO THAT
BECAUSE I SAT HERE AND LISTENED
TO THE STORIES. I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE IT, BUT BUT A LIST OF
TEACHERS WENT THROUGH MY MIND
WHO GOT ME THROUGH AND TO
COLLEGE TO BE ABLE TO BECOME THE
PERSON I AM. BUT THIS TOOL IS
FOR THOSE TEACHERS. THIS CAME
THROUGH THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE,
SO WITH GREAT APPRECIATION AND A
SHOUT OUT, I KNOW WE HAVE
TEACHERS HERE, BUT WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DID TO
HELP ME, US AND WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO WITH THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO BE ABLE TO HELP
OUR KIDS IN SCHOOL EVERY SINGLE
DAY GOING FORWARD, I URGE AND I
VOTE FOR AB 1955. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ATKINS. SENATOR OCHOA,
BOGH. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'VE REALLY APPRECIATED ALL THE
STORIES THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED
TODAY BY MY COLLEAGUES. AND I
HAVE GREAT HEART AND SENSITIVITY
FOR ALL OF THEM AND GREAT
RESPECT. I WISH LIFE WASN'T AS
HARD AS IT IS FOR SOME. WITH
THAT, I'M GOING TO PREFACE THAT
THIS BILL IS PUTTING EVERYBODY
TOGETHER WITH THE LGBT COMMUNITY
TOGETHER, BUT IN REALITY, I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT GOING BACK
TO THE SCHOOL BOARDS. WHAT
PROMPTED THIS LEGISLATION TODAY?
HERE SCHOOL BOARDS HAVE BEEN
PASSING POLICIES THAT INFORM
PARENTS WHEN THEIR MINOR STUDENT
IS ASKING ME TO PUBLICLY BE
TREATED AS A DIFFERENT GENDER
THAN THEIR BIOLOGICAL SEX. THAT
IS WHEN THE STUDENT IS ASKING
FOR THE SCHOOL TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE STUDENT'S SOCIAL TRANSITION.
THE POLICIES IN THE SCHOOL
BOARDS DON'T MENTION SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OFTEN. WHAT MOST
PARENTS ARE MOST AFRAID OF IS
THAT THEIR CHILD ADOPTING AN
IDENTITY THAT BRINGS WITH IT
HEIGHTENED SUICIDE RISKS AND
IRREVERSIBLE MEDICAL
INTERVENTION, AND BLOCKING
PARENTS FROM HELPING THEIR
CHILD. STUDIES SHOW LONG TERM
SOCIAL TRANSITION LEADS DIRECTLY
TO MEDICALIZATION. AND
FOUNDATIONALLY, I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT MY COLLEAGUES ARE
AWARE THAT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION ENCOURAGED THE
900 PLUS SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ADOPT ADMINISTRATIVE.
REGULATIONS 5145.3. 5145 I'M
SORRY. 5145.3. REQUIRED STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS TO USE OTHER
STUDENT CHOSEN NAME AND
PRONOUNS, OR THEY COULD BE
DISCIPLINED FOR DISCRIMINATION
AND LIKEWISE REQUIRE THAT THAT
AND I QUOTE. THE COMPLIANCE
OFFICER SHALL ARRANGE A MEETING
WITH THE STUDENT AND, IF
APPROPRIATE, HIS OR HER PARENTS
OR GUARDIANS. CLEARLY. 5145.3
MAKES INVOLVING THE PARENTS
DISCRETIONARY. BUT REALLY IT IS
A CHILD WHO IS DECIDING, JUST
LIKE AB 1955 DOES. AB 195 TODAY
FIVE FIVE. I'M SORRY. AB 1955 IS
SEEKING TO CODIFY 5145.3 INTO
LAW.
MY READ OF THE PARENTAL
NOTIFICATION POLICIES IS THAT
THERE IS NO OBLIGATION TO
INVOLVE THE PARENT. IF A STUDENT
TELLS A TEACHER THAT HE IS
TRANSGENDER, BUT THERE IS WHEN
THE STUDENT ASKS THAT THE SCHOOL
USE PRONOUNS OR A NAME OR PERMIT
HIM TO USE FACILITIES FOR THE
OPPOSITE OR CHANGE HIS RECORDS
SIMPLY. ONCE A STUDENT REQUESTS
A SCHOOL TO PARTICIPATE IN HIS
SOCIAL TRANSITION, THAT IS WHEN
PARENTS NEED TO BE NOTIFIED. IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE STUDENT IS
OUTING HIMSELF TO THE SCHOOL AND
OTHER STUDENTS. THIS REMOVES
WHATEVER PRIVACY RIGHTS MIGHT
EXIST. THE FEDERAL JUDGE IN
MIRABELLI VERSUS OLSON CASE
STATES IN HIS 36 PAGE ORDER
DATED SEPTEMBER 14TH, 2023, THAT
ACCORDING TO FERPA, THE PRIVACY
RIGHT OF A CHILD TAKES SECOND
PLACE TO HIS OR HER PARENTS
RIGHT TO KNOW, AND THAT A
SECRECY POLICY IS AS FOREIGN TO
FEDERAL CONSTITUTIONAL AND
STATUTORY LAW AS IT IS MEDICALLY
UNWISE. THE JUDGE ALSO CONFIRMED
THAT NO AUTHORITY EXISTS,
CONFERRING UPON CHILDREN A
PRIVACY RIGHT IN THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY AS AGAINST THEIR OWN
PARENTS. QUOTE. CONCERNING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO PRIVACY FOR MINORS AND
REGULATIONS LIKE A PARENT'S
SECRECY POLICY, THE STATE'S
HIGHEST COURT HAS NOT HAD
OCCASION TO ISSUE A BINDING
INTERPRETATION AND NO STATE
APPELLATE COURT DECISIONS HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED. PARENTS RIGHTS
ARE SUPERIOR TO A RIGHT OF A
PRIVACY BELONGING TO THEIR CHILD
. A PARENT MAY CURTAIL A CHILD'S
EXERCISE OF CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS BECAUSE A PARENT'S OAN
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTED LIBERTY
INCLUDES THE RIGHT TO BRING UP
THEIR CHILD. THE JUDGE DENOUNCED
THE ESCONDIDO PARENTS SECRECY
POLICY. POLICY 5145.3. THE
SCHOOL'S POLICY IS A TRIFECTA OF
HARM. IT HARMS THE CHILD WHO
NEEDS PARENTAL GUIDANCE AND
POSSIBLY MENTAL HEALTH
INTERVENTION TO DETERMINE IF THE
INCONGRUOUS IS ORGANIC, OR
WHETHER IT IS THE RESULT OF
BULLYING, PEER PRESSURE OR
FLEETING IMPULSE. IT HARMS THE
PARENTS BY DEPRIVING THEM OF THE
LONG RECOGNIZED 14TH AMENDMENT
RIGHT TO CARE, GUIDE AND MAKE
HEALTH CARE DECISIONS FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. AND FINALLY, IT HARMS
PLAINTIFFS WHO ARE COMPELLED TO
VIOLATE THE PARENTS RIGHT BY
FORCING PLAINTIFFS TO CONCEAL
INFORMATION THEY FEEL IS
CRITICAL FOR THE WELFARE OF
THEIR STUDENTS, VIOLATING
PLAINTIFFS RELIGIOUS BELIEFS. WE
HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE ELEVATED
RISK OF SUICIDE OF TRANS
IDENTIFIED YOUTH. THE FIGURES GO
FROM 41% HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
SUICIDE ALL THE WAY TO 87, WHICH
WAS THE FIGURE FROM ATTORNEY
GENERAL COMPLAINT AGAINST THE
CHINO VALLEY SCHOOL DISTRICT. IF
SUICIDE IS SUCH A RISK AND WE
KNOW THAT SUICIDES DO NOT HAPPEN
AT SCHOOL, BUT THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OCCUR AT HOME, WHY
WOULD WE NOT ALERT THE PARENTS
TO THE HEIGHTENED SUICIDE RISK
SO THAT THEY CAN LOCK UP POISONS
, PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND BE
VIGILANT, VIGILANT AS WELL AS
GET THEIR CHILD INTO THERAPY? WE
CAN'T JUSTIFY HIDING A CHILD'S
GENDER DYSPHORIA FROM THEIR
PARENTS HORRIBLY. TWO OUT OF 315
OF THOSE YOUTH SORRY, THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTION OF HEALTH
STUDY THAT INVOLVED 315 YOUTH AT
FOUR MAJOR US HOSPITALS, THE
CHILDREN WERE SUPPORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBERS IN THEIR TRANS
IDENTIFIED AND INTENDED TO BE A
MULTIDISCIPLINARY MENTAL TEAM.
HORRIBLY, TWO OUT OF THE 315 OF
THOSE YOUTH ENDED THEIR LIVES
DURING THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
STUDY THAT IS MORE THAN 40 TIMES
THE SUICIDE RATE OF THEIR PEERS
SOCIALLY AND MEDICALLY
TRANSITIONING A CHILD CERTAINLY
DID NOT PREVENT THE SUICIDE. A
NEW US STUDY, I'M NOT GOING TO
READ THAT FOR ESSENCE OF THE
TIME. I'M GOING TO GO FOR DOCTOR
ERICA ANDERSON, A TRANS
IDENTIFIED MAN AND PSYCHOLOGIST
WHO PRACTICE AT UCSF'S GENDER
CLINIC AND IS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE US PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF TRANSGENDER
HEALTH, FILED A DECLARATION IN A
COUPLE OF CALIFORNIA CASES.
DOCTOR ANDERSON STATES THAT
PARENT INVOLVEMENT IS NECESSARY,
THAT PERMISSION TO READ Ó.
PERMISSION TO READ. I'M SORRY.
ALL RIGHT. I'M GOING TO GRANT IT
PERMISSION TO READ, STATES
PARENT INVOLVEMENT IS NECESSARY
TO OBTAIN PROFESSIONAL
ASSISTANCE FOR A CHILD OR
ADOLESCENT EXPERIENCING GENDER
INCONGRUENCE, TO PROVIDE
ACCURATE DIAGNOSIS, AND TO TREAT
ANY GENDER DYSPHORIA OR OTHER
COEXISTING CONDITIONS. AS DOCTOR
ANDERSON ALSO SAYS, PERMISSION
TO CONTINUE READING OKAY.
PERMISSION TO READ GRANTED A
SCHOOL FACILITATED TRANSITION
WITHOUT PARENTAL CONSENT
INTERFERES WITH PARENTS ABILITY
TO PURSUE A CAREFUL ASSESSMENT
AND OR THERAPEUTIC APPROACH.
PRIOR TO TRANSITIONING. PREVENTS
PARENTS FROM MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT WHETHER A TRANSITION WILL
BE BEST FOR THEIR CHILD, AND
CREATES UNNECESSARY TENSION IN
THE PARENT CHILD RELATIONSHIP.
NOR IS FACILITATE A DOUBLE LIFE
FOR SOME CHILDREN IN WHICH THEY
PRESENT AS TRANSGENDER. IN SOME
CONTEXTS, BUT CISGENDER IN OTHER
CONTEXTS. IN IN THEIR BEST
INTEREST, NO PROFESSIONAL
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THAT I'M
AWARE OF RECOMMENDS THAT SCHOOL
OFFICIAL FACILITATE THE SOCIAL
TRANSITION OF A CHILD OR
ADOLESCENT WITHOUT PARENTAL
KNOWLEDGE AND CONSENT. IT'S
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE THIS SPACE
. INCREDIBLY PERSONAL TO
FAMILIES. BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT HISTORICALLY, PARENTS HAVE
ALWAYS WANTED THE BEST FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. WHEN THOUGHTS OF
SUICIDE. HAVE ENTERED ATTEMPTS
OF SUICIDE. HAVE ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS. HAVE HAPPENED
TO CHILDREN. I CAN ASSURE THAT
REGARDLESS OF HOW PARENTS FEEL
ABOUT THEIR CHILD'S GENDER
IDENTITY, SEXUAL ORIENTATION,
PARENTS WILL ALWAYS STEP UP AND
LOVE THEIR CHILD. MAYBE NOT
ALWAYS, BUT THE MAJORITY. THE
MAJORITY OF PARENTS WOULD. I'M
GOING TO END BY JUST REFERENCING
COURT CASE IN HODGIN VERSUS
MINNESOTA 497 US FOUR SEVEN,
1990, THE COURT SAID A NATURAL
PARENT WHO HAS DEMONSTRATED
SUFFICIENT COMMITMENT TO HIS OR
HER CHILDREN IS THEREAFTER
ENTITLED TO RAISE THEIR CHILDREN
FREE FROM UNDUE STATE
INTERFERENCE WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION, SENATOR
GROVE? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'M JUST GOING TO TAKE A MINUTE
BECAUSE I HAVE DEEP RESPECT FOR
THE AUTHOR AND MY COLLEAGUES
THAT SPOKE PREVIOUSLY ON THE
FLOOR FROM BOTH SIDES, BUT THE
PERSONAL STORIES THAT CAME FROM
OUR COLLEAGUES, FROM
SPECIFICALLY THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
AND THOSE THAT ARE ELECTED HERE
IN OFFICE THAT REPRESENT, THEM
STATEWIDE, YOU KNOW, LIKE ALL OF
US, WE ALL HAVE INDIVIDUALS IN
OUR COMMUNITY, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON, WHEN SHE WAS
INTRODUCING THE BILL OR, TALKING
IN THE PRESENTATION, SHE SAID, I
WANT TO DIAL DOWN ON THE
CONFLICTS OR DIAL DOWN. I DON'T
REMEMBER THE WORD, BUT IT WAS
LIKE, DIAL DOWN THE RHETORIC. I
GUESS YOU'D SAY. AND SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT, YOU
KNOW, FRANTICALLY READING THE
BILL WHILE WE WERE SITTING HERE
AND LISTENING TO THE DEBATE,
THIS TEXT IN 217, PERMISSION TO
READ. PERMISSION TO READ? YES
IT'S GRANTED ABOVE 217. THERE'S
SEVERAL PARAGRAPHS THAT TALK
ABOUT, SEVERAL, RESOURCES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE IN THE, THE
LANGUAGE THAT GOES THROUGH THAT
IS, IT INCLUDES FAMILIES. BUT
UNDER SECTION 217 OF THE BILL,
SECTION A1, THE DEPARTMENT, THE
DEPARTMENT, MEANING THE
DEPARTMENT SHALL DEVELOP
RESOURCES OR, AS APPROPRIATE,
UPDATE EXISTING RESOURCES FOR
SUPPORTS AND COMMUNITY RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT OF PARENTS,
GUARDIANS, FAMILIES OF LESBIAN,
GAY, BISEXUAL, TRANSGENDER,
QUEER AND QUESTIONING LGBTQ
PUPILS AND STRATEGIES TO
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR LGBTQ
PUPILS AND THEREBY REMOVE
OVERALL SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
IMPROVE OVERALL SCHOOL COMMUNITY
CLIMATE. THE RESOURCES SHALL BE
DESIGNED AND USED TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD'S OPERATED SO THE SCHOOL
BOARD'S WILL MAKE THE DECISION
ON HOW THESE RESOURCES WERE
DESIGNED. BUT THE DEPARTMENT IS
RECOMMENDING UNDER SECTION TWO,
THE DEPARTMENT SHALL DEVELOP THE
SUPPORTS AND COMMUNITY RESOURCES
FOR PARENTS, GUARDIANS AND
FAMILIES OF LGBT, LGBTQ PUPILS
IN COLLABORATION WITH PARENTS IN
COLLABORATION WITH PARENTS,
GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES,
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
LGBTQ PUPILS. THE DEPARTMENT
SHALL PERIODICALLY UPDATE THE
SUPPORTS OF THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES WITH AGAIN PARENTS,
GUARDIANS, FAMILIES AND LGBTQ
PUPILS THAT REFLECT CHANGES IN
THE LAW AS USED IN THIS SECTION.
SCHOOL BASED SUPPORTS AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR THE
SUPPORT OF PARENTS, GUARDIANS
AND FAMILIES OF LGBT C¯ PUPILS
INCLUDE, BUT ARE NOT LIMITED.
ALL THE FOLLOWING A PARENTS,
GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES OF LGBTQ
PUPILS. SUPPORT GROUPS AND OR
AFFINITY CLUBS AND
ORGANIZATIONS. BE SAFE PLACES,
SAFE SPACES. EXCUSE ME FOR
PARENTS, GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES
OF LGBTQ PUPILS, SEE
ANTI-BULLYING AND HARASSMENT
POLICIES AND RELATED COMPLAINT
PROCEDURES FOR PARENTS,
GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES TO HAVE
ACCESS. COUNSELING SERVICES IS D
EAST SCHOOL STAFF WHO HAVE
RECEIVED ANTI-BIAS OR OTHER
TRAINING AIMED AT SUPPORTING
LGBTQ YOUTH AND THEIR PARENTS,
GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES. F
SUICIDE PREVENTION POLICIES
RELATED TO PROCEDURES FOR
PARENTS, GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES
TO ACCESS, AS USED IN THIS
SECTION, THE COMMUNITY RESOURCES
WILL SUPPORT PARENTS, GUARDIANS.
FAMILIES OF LGBTQ PUPILS
INCLUDED, BUT NOT LIMITED TO
BOTH OF THE FOLLOWING LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE SUPPORT TO PARENTS,
GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES OF LGBTQ
YOUTH. LOCAL PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS WITH EXPERIENCE
IN TREATING AND SUPPORTING
PARENTS, FAMILIES AND GUARDIANS
OF LGBT YOUTH. YOU COULD GO ON
AND ON AND ON THROUGH THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL. I'M JUST
SAYING YOU COULD GO ON AND ON
AND ON THROUGH THE LANGUAGE OF
THIS BILL. I THINK WHEN MY
COLLEAGUE SAYS, DIAL DOWN THE
RHETORIC, WE NEED TO DIAL IT
DOWN. THE BOTTOM LINE IS, IS
THAT THIS BILL SAYS THAT
TEACHERS SHOULD NOT BE MANDATED
REPORTERS LISTENING TO THE
PERSONAL STORIES OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ON MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE AND
ARE ON OUR SIDE OF THE AISLE. IF
WE COULD ALL TELL HEARTS, HEART,
HEART WRENCHING STORIES ABOUT
OUR UPBRINGING. I THINK WE GREW
UP IN A DIFFERENT ERA. I THINK
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS. MY MOM
WAS VERY POOR, SINGLE MOM. MY
DAD WAS A JERK. I SHOULDN'T HAVE
SAID THAT, BUT WHATEVER. AND WE
USED TO, LIKE, STEAL POTATOES
OUT OF THE FIELD TO EAT AND NOW
I'M ONE OF 40, AND I WENT TO A
NAVAL CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOL,
AND I WAS A FIGHTER, IN CASE YOU
GUYS DIDN'T KNOW, THAT HIGH
SCHOOL. BUT SO WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS, BUT THERE
ARE VERY TOUCHING STORIES
FRANTICALLY READING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATION, WHICH I HAVE NOT
READ ALL OF IT YET, BUT
EVERYTHING THAT I DID READ TO
YOU IS IN THERE. AND THIS POLICY
THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DEVELOP
IS THE WAY I UNDERSTAND IT. AND
I WOULD LIKE THE AUTHOR TO
CORRECT ME IF I AM WRONG, IS
THAT THEY DON'T WANT TEACHERS TO
BE MANDATED REPORTERS. THAT'S IN
THIS PARTICULAR SPACE. NOW, IF
THEY'RE BEING ABUSED OR THEY'RE
BEING THERE'S CHILD NEGLECT,
NEGLECT, ALL THOSE OTHER
POLICIES. BUT IN THIS PARTICULAR
SPACE, THEY DON'T WANT THE
TEACHER OR I'M SORRY, I SHOULD
GET THE LANGUAGE OUT AGAIN.
TEACHERS, COUNSELORS,
CONTRACTORS, JANITORIAL
PERSONNEL, ANY SCHOOL PERSONNEL
THAT'S PAID BY THE SCHOOL, I'M
ASSUMING, OR CONTRACTED BY THE
SCHOOL. THEY DON'T WANT THEM TO
BE MANDATED REPORTERS IN THIS
SPACE. EVERYTHING IN THIS BILL
INCLUDES FAMILIES, GUARDS AND
THE WHOLE LANGUAGE. I JUST READ
ABOUT THE LGBT Q SPACE COMING
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP THESE
POLICIES. I'M REALLY GETTING GET
IN TROUBLE FOR THIS NEXT STEP.
AND I KNOW GREG BURT IS FLIPPING
OUT RIGHT NOW. NOBODY ON THIS
FLOOR. I DON'T CARE WHO YOU ARE.
NOBODY ON THIS FLOOR WANTS LGBT
KIDS TARGETED. I HAVE A PASTOR
FRIEND OF MINE WHO NOW WORKS FOR
CAPC, AND THEY ADOPTED A LITTLE
BOY, FROM ONE OF THE MISSION
FIELDS THAT WE WENT ON TO AS A
AS A KID. AND, HE CAME OUT TO
THEM AND HE HE'S TRANSITIONING,
AND THEY LOVE HIM AND HE'S PART
OF THEIR FAMILY. BUT BASED ON
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE HAPPENING
TODAY, NOT EVERYBODY HAS THAT
EXPERIENCE. I CAN'T FIND
ANYTHING IN HERE, IN LANGUAGE.
AND AGAIN, I'VE FRANTICALLY
LOOKED THROUGH IT AND I HAVEN'T
TALKED TO A CONSULTANT ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I'VE JUST BEEN LISTENING
TO I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S BEEN
GOING AROUND ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. AND I FEEL LIKE I'M
IN MY SPACE ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. WHEN SCOTT BUDNICK
BROUGHT ME YOUTH OFFENDERS AND I
LISTENED TO THE CONVERSATION IN
MY OFFICE, AND ONE YOUNG KID
SAYS, I DROVE THE CAR, THE OTHER
YOUNG KID SAYS, I PULLED THE
TRIGGER AND THEN THIS. I'M LIKE,
WHAT'S YOUR STORY? IT WAS AN
OLDER MAN. HE'S TWISTING HIS HAT
IN HIS HAND AND HE GOES, MY SON
WOULD BE ALIVE TODAY IF THIS
POLICY WAS AVAILABLE IN THIS
STATE. SO HE'S ACTUALLY
CAMPAIGNING FOR A BILL THAT
THOSE TWO KIDS THAT KILLED HIS
SON TO TRY TO SOLVE PROBLEMS. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM IS. I THINK LOVE I
MEAN, JESUS SAID LOVE. YOU KNOW,
I SAY THAT I'VE SAID THIS
BEFORE, MAYBE NOT ON THIS FLOOR,
BUT I LOVE THE LORD WITH ALL MY
HEART. AND I KNOW GOD DIDN'T
SEND HIS SON TO THIS WORLD TO
CONDEMN THIS WORLD. AND I'M
PRETTY SURE HE DIDN'T SEND
ANYBODY ELSE. SO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE SOLUTION IS, BUT I DO
KNOW THAT THE BILL DOES INCLUDE
PARENTS GUARDIANS FOR THE
SOLUTION. AND I DO KNOW, OR MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL IS
THAT IT DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
PARENTS, TEACHERS OR CONTRACTORS
IN A SCHOOL TO BE MANDATED.
REPORTERS THERE HAS TO BE A
HAPPY SOLUTION WHERE PARENTS CAN
BE ENGAGED AND INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE ALTHOUGH, YOU
KNOW, LIKE MY COLLEAGUE SAID
BEHIND ME, HE SAID, IF PARENTS
AREN'T INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS,
IT DOESN'T WORK. IF PARENTS
AREN'T INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS.
AND WE DO COME ACROSS SITUATIONS
WHERE PARENTS ARE HOSTILE TO
THIS SITUATION WITH THEIR
CHILDREN, THEN, YOU KNOW,
AUTHORITIES NEED TO KNOW, IF
PARENTS AND WHEN I SAY HOSTILE,
I MEAN HOSTILE. I MEAN, I'M NOT
TALKING. I, I'M NOT TALKING, YOU
KNOW, THE DAD SAYING I'M NOT
GOING TO LET YOU DO THAT. YOU
KNOW, THAT'S SOMETHING YOU ALL
WORK THROUGH. BUT I'M TALKING
ABOUT HOSTILE, DETRIMENTAL HARM
TO THE CHILD, I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE, FROM YUCCA VALLEY.
RIGHT. SORRY, SORRY, I ROBE, I
AGREE WITH ROBE THAT YOU KNOW,
PARENTS SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
THIS PROCESS, AND IT APPEARS
THAT THE BILL ALLOWS THAT TO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS. THERE
ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT NEED
TO BE ANSWERED. I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY. I LIKE MY I
UNDERSTAND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BIEBER. SCHOOL BOARDS ARE
ELECTED BY THE PEOPLE CLOSEST TO
THE PEOPLE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES,
I UNDERSTAND MY COLLEAGUE, THE
FORMER SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES, COMMENTS THAT, YOU
KNOW, ABOUT THE SOUTH AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. SO THERE ARE A LOT OF
GOOD ARGUMENTS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS, THIS ARGUMENT. BUT WE NEED
TO COME TOGETHER AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT, RIGHT, WHAT WORKS. BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THERE IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT AND IN
OTHER DISTRICTS THAT ARE
FIGHTING HARD TO GAIN CONTROL OF
THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES. AGAIN,
WITHOUT GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE
IN ANY WAY, WITHOUT GOVERNMENT
INTERFERENCE ABOUT ANYTHING.
PARENTS WANT TO BE ABLE TO RAISE
THEIR CHILDREN. THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO RAISE THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO. SO I
DON'T WANT TO SAY I APPRECIATE
THE FLOOR DEBATE BECAUSE IT GAVE
ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO READ THE
BILL, I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL,
SUSAN, I JUST CAN'T, I HAVE TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS MORE ABOUT
THIS THAN I DO. BUT WHAT I'VE
READ SO FAR, I WILL TELL YOU
THAT MY. UNLESS THERE'S SOME IN
CODE SECTIONS, BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
HAD TIME TO READ THE CODE
SECTIONS AND DETERMINE WHAT THAT
IS, AND ANOTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH. ON THE FACE OF THIS BILL,
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY DON'T WANT
TEACHERS TO BE MANDATED
REPORTERS AND THAT PARENTS WILL
BE INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS TO
DEVELOP SOMETHING FOR THE LGBTQ
STUDENTS, BECAUSE I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE ROBE THAT, I DON'T
THINK EVERY PARENT IS LIKE THIS.
I THINK MOST PARENTS AND PARENTS
I KNOW IN MY DISTRICT ARE LOVING
AND ACCEPTING AND WORKING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WITHOUT ANY
GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE, BUT IT
GRIEVED MY HEART FROM WHAT I
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND SO AND
OTHERS. BUT, AND I THINK
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE LOVED AND
ACCEPTED. I DON'T THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO I DON'T THINK THAT
BELIEF SHOULD BE PUSHED ON ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER FROM EITHER
SIDE. AND, CONTRARY TO SOME OF
THE STORIES THAT ARE ON THE
FLOOR, MY JESUS LOVES EVERYBODY
EQUALLY, NO MATTER WHO THEY ARE.
AND WHERE THEY'RE AT. AND, I
KNOW I'M A HORRIBLE EXAMPLE OF
HIM, BUT I TRY TO BE GOOD, IT
DOESN'T WORK EVERY DAY. YOU CAN
TELL, BUT, I THINK WE SHOULD
JUST LOOK INTO THIS LEGISLATION
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE IT SO
THAT THERE'S A COMMUNICATION
WHERE THE RHETORIC IS DIALED
DOWN ON BOTH SIDES, AND PEOPLE
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT MOVE FORWARD THAT WAY,
INSTEAD OF HAVING IT CRAMMED THE
WAY IT'S BEEN CRAMMED THROUGH.
AND, THERE NEEDS TO BE A DEEPER
DIALOG, IS WHAT I'M SAYING. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SENATOR EGGMAN, YOU MAY CONCLUDE
THE DEBATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR. PRESIDENT AND I HAVE
APPRECIATED ALL MY COLLEAGUES
AND ALL THE DEBATE, AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. KIDS AND PARENTS, IT IS
AN EMOTIONAL ISSUE, AND I THINK
WE HEARD THAT FROM EVERYBODY.
AND I'D ALSO JUST LIKE TO SAY,
ON BEHALF OF THE LGBTQ CAUCUS,
AREN'T WE FABULOUS? AREN'T WE
FABULOUS? I MEAN, WE SHOW UP AND
WE SMILE AND WE'RE FUN AND WE'RE
ALL THOSE THINGS. BUT WHEN YOU
HEAR THE STRUGGLES THAT WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH, I HOPE YOU REALLY
APPRECIATE HOW FABULOUS WE ARE,
AND I SAY THAT WITH PRIDE. AND I
ALSO SAY THAT SO YOU KNOW HOW
DETERMINED WE ARE NOT TO LET
THIS HAPPEN TO ANOTHER
GENERATION OF KIDS, THAT THIS IS
WHY WE ARE SO SET AND FIRM ON
SAYING, WE'VE GOT TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR KIDS AND KEEP THEM SAFE.
AND YOU'LL SAY, THAT'S PARENTS
ROLES. WE'RE NOT GETTING IN
BETWEEN PARENTS ROLES. PARENTS
STILL HAVE THESE KIDS ALL THE
TIME. PARENTS HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CHILD. THE
SCHOOL IS NOT THE CONDUIT FOR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CHILD. AND
I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY WHO WOULD
THINK THAT THE SCHOOL IS THE
CONDUIT OR THE PLATFORM FOR OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CHILD.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME. AND
THE IDEA THAT LOCAL CONTROL, I
MEAN, I HEAR THAT I WAS IN A
CITY COUNCIL, BUT THE FORMER
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES
SAID, I MEAN, THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
WE HAD WHEN, WHEN, WHEN PEOPLE
WOULD NOT LET AFRICAN AMERICANS
INTO SCHOOLS, THEY COULDN'T GO
BECAUSE THAT WAS LOCAL CONTROL.
I DON'T WHY WHY WOULD WE WANT TO
CREATE A SYSTEM LIKE THAT AGAIN?
WHY WOULD WE WANT TO CREATE A
SYSTEM LIKE THAT AGAIN? WE DON'T
I DON'T BELIEVE WE DO. THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION SIMPLY SAYS
WE'RE GOING TO PREPARE WITH
PARENTS INFORMATION TO FOR
PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE IT SO
THEY CAN HELP THEIR KIDS, THAT
KIDS AND KIDS DO HAVE A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY AND WE'RE NOT
SUPERSEDING THE FERPA LAW. THERE
IS NO SUPERSEDING. THERE IS NO
SUPERSEDING OF THE FERPA LAW ON
THIS. PARENTS STILL HAVE THE
RIGHT. THERE'S NO SECRET FILES
THAT THE LAW YOU'RE REFERRING TO
SAYS PARENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
THE STUDENTS EDUCATION FILES. WE
DON'T TOUCH THAT. WE DON'T TOUCH
THAT. AND I HEARD YOUR YOUR
PERSON THAT YOU WERE QUOTING
FROM. I HEARD THAT TESTIMONY,
SEEMED TO INDICATE THAT THERE
WAS SECRET FILE, SECRET GAY
FILES THAT WOULD BE KEPT AT
SCHOOLS, THAT WOULD BE KEPT FROM
PARENTS. THAT'S ABSURD. TEACHERS
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO DO THE
THINGS THAT WE ASK THEM TO DO,
LET ALONE KEEP SECRET. GAY FILES
FROM PARENTS. THAT IS
RIDICULOUS. MEMBERS THINK ABOUT
THIS. ALL RIGHT? WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS PROVIDE INFORMATION
FOR PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
IF THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THEIR KIDS BE SUPPORTIVE. WE'RE
SAYING KIDS HAVE A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY. WE'RE SAYING SCHOOL
BOARDS SHOULD NOT MANDATE
TEACHERS TO CALL PARENTS AND BE
THE GENDER POLICE. AND WE'RE
SAYING KIDS HAVE A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY. THAT'S ALL WE'RE
SAYING. THAT'S ALL WE'RE SAYING.
AND YOU CAN MAKE UP AS MUCH ELSE
AS YOU WANT TO SAY ABOUT IT. AND
YOU CAN SAY THIS IS ABOUT
MEDICALLY AND SOCIALLY
TRANSITIONING CHILDREN AT
SCHOOL. HOW COULD THAT HAPPEN?
HOW COULD THAT HAPPEN WITHOUT A
PARENT KNOWING? I WOULD ASK, HOW
COULD THAT HAPPEN WITHOUT A
PARENT KNOWING UNLESS THAT
PARENT IS LIVING UNDER A TABLE
SOMEWHERE, AS AS MY, COLLEAGUE,
THE FORMER FIREFIGHTER SAID,
EVERYBODY KNEW. EVERYBODY KNEW
IT WASN'T A SECRET. SO THEN WHAT
ARE YOU SAYING? IF THERE'S NO
SECRETS, THAT THERE'S NO NEED TO
BE TELLING? BECAUSE I'LL TELL
YOU. WHEN THE SCHOOL CALLED MY
FAMILY TO TELL THEM I WAS DATING
AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN YOUNG MAN,
THAT COMMUNICATED TO MY PARENTS
THAT SOMETHING WAS WRONG, THAT
SOMETHING WAS WRONG WITH WHAT I
WAS DOING. THAT IS THE WAY IT
WAS COMMUNICATED. AND THAT IS
WHAT THESE POLICIES DO. ALERT
PARENTS THAT SOMETHING IS WRONG
AND SOMETHING SHOULD BE DONE.
LET'S KEEP ALL OF OUR KIDS SAFE.
LET'S TONE DOWN THE RHETORIC AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 1955. THANK YOU,
SENATOR EGGMAN. ALL DEBATE
HAVING BEEN COMPLETED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. AYE, I'LL RODA-GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLI. NÓ. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR. I
MEAN, I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NØ.
NILO NO. OKOBO NO. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GIL.
JONES NÓ. LIMÓN STERN. ON A VOTE
OF 29 TO 8, THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY. ASK THE CLERK TO READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY. MR.
PRESIDENT, I'M DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED ON ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED, SENATE
BILL 154 167 AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO
CONCUR AND SET AMENDMENTS. SUE
PARKER, CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY, ABOVE BILLS ORDERED TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. OKAY,
MEMBERS. SO WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
OUR SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. THIS IS
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER ONE.
HOPEFULLY WE WON'T HAVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER TWO
TODAY. AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM 159. THIS IS SENATE BILL
154. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 154 BY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW, AN ACT
RELATING TO EDUCATION FINANCE
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY
THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. WE'LL TURN TO OUR
BUDGET CHAIR, SENATOR WEINER,
FOR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
SB 154 IS A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
RELATING TO EDUCATION, FINANCE,
SPECIFICALLY TO PROP 98
SUSPENSION, THE BILL IS A
CORNERSTONE TO THE BALANCED
BUDGET THAT WE'RE PASSING TODAY
AND IS CRITICAL TO PROTECTING
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND PROGRAMS OUTSIDE OF PROP 98
FROM REDUCTIONS IN ONGOING
SPENDING. THE BILL SUSPENDS PROP
98, THE PROP 98 GUARANTEE, AND
THE CURRENT 2023 2024 FISCAL
YEAR, TO $98.5 BILLION AND
REQUIRES FUTURE FUNDING
OBLIGATIONS TOWARDS THE
GUARANTEE IN THE OUT YEARS.
THESE ACTIONS ARE ALIGNED WITH
WHAT IS ALLOWED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. THÀNH,
FOR CONTEXT, WITHOUT THIS
SUSPENSION IN THE GUARANTEE IN
THE CURRENT YEAR FOR PROP 98
WOULD BE $106.8 BILLION, AND
THAT WOULD MEAN REDUCTIONS
ELSEWHERE. THE SCHOOL RAINY DAY
FUND WILL COVER THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE REVISED GUARANTEE
LEVEL AND ONGOING COSTS FOR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
WHICH WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE
EDUCATION OMNIBUS TRAILER BILL,
WITH THESE ACTIONS COMBINED, THE
BUDGET WILL BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
PROP 98 SPENDING LEVELS AND
LEAVE A CUSHION FOR FUTURE
YEARS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WIENER. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO. TROBO
NO. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE
. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMILED. CUEVAS.
AYE STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO.
THAT'S A VOTE OF 29 EIGHT ON THE
URGENCY. 29 EIGHT. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 160 BEFORE I GO TO
SECRETARY TO READ. I JUST WANT
TO ASK EVERYONE TO KEEP THE
VOLUME DOWN AND GO TO THE BACK
OF THE CHAMBER. IF YOU NEED TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 167 BY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW, AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION, THEREFORE, TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES SB 167 IS
A BUDGET TRAILER BILL RELATING
TO TAXATION. THE BILL ENACTS A
NET OPERATING LOSS SUSPENSION
AND BUSINESS TAX CREDIT
LIMITATION FOR THE 2020 TO 24,
2025 AND 2026 TAX YEARS,
PROVIDING THE STATE ADDITIONAL
REVENUES TO PROTECT SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS DURING THIS
DIFFICULT BUDGET TIME. THE BILL
INCLUDES INTENT LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE REFUNDABILITY FOR
IMPACTED TAXPAYERS FOR THE
FOREGONE USE OF BUSINESS TAX
CREDITS DURING THE LIMITATION
PERIOD. IT ELIMINATES A VARIETY
OF OTHER TAX DEDUCTIONS,
INCLUDING OIL AND GAS SUBSIDY,
TAX TAX, TAX SUBSIDIES AND A BAD
DEBT DEDUCTION FOR LENDERS. IT
INCLUDES A VARIETY OF OTHER
TAXATION CHANGES AND TECHNICAL
CLEANUP PROVISIONS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR NILO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. THERE ARE LOTS OF
PROBLEMS WITH ALL OF THESE TAX
PROPOSALS. I'LL JUST GO THROUGH
THREE OF THEM. THREE OF THE
FOUR, THE R&D CREDIT. THIS COMES
UNDER ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THIS
IS AN ALLOWANCE THAT OTHER
STATES HAVE. FOR FULLER TECH
COMPANIES. BUT OTHERS TO THAT,
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE ARE
INCONSISTENT IN OUR ALLOWANCE
THIS WE WILL JUST ENCOURAGE
OTHER COMPANIES TO LEAVE THE
STATE. I REFER TO THE LIST THAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER
REFERENCED EARLIER. I THINK WE
NEED TO BE A LOT MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT THAN WE EVIDENTLY
SEEM TO BE WITH REGARD TO THE
NET OPERATING LOSS LOSS
PROVISION, I PUT THIS UNDER THE
CATEGORY OF KICK THEM WHILE
THEY'RE DOWN. THIS IS A FAIRNESS
ALLOWANCE. AS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST HAS POINTED OUT, IN OUR
SYSTEM OF TAXATION, OFTEN WHEN
COMPANIES ARE DEVELOPING OR
OTHERWISE OPERATING, BUT LOSING
MONEY, THEY ARE DEPLETING THEIR
CAPITAL. WHEN THEY START MAKING
MONEY AGAIN, THEY NEED TO
REFRESH THEIR CAPITAL, WHICH IS
GOING TO BE CONSIDERABLY
HAMPERED IF WE IMMEDIATELY
REQUIRE THEM TO START PAYING
TAXES. ONCE THEY MAKE MONEY
AFTER A YEAR OR YEARS OF LOSS. I
WOULD ALSO ADD TWO OTHER THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, WE PLAY AROUND
WITH THIS PROVISION OF THE TAX
CODE FOR CURRENTLY. IT'S GETTING
TO THE POINT WHERE BUSINESSES
REALLY CAN'T DEPEND UPON IT.
BUSINESSES NEED CERTAINTY. THIS
CERTAINTY DOESN'T EXIST WITH A
NET OPERATING LOSS BECAUSE OF
OUR PRACTICE, NOT JUST THIS
BUDGET YEAR, BUT OTHERS TOO. THE
OTHER THING IS THIS BECAUSE OF
THE THREE YEAR, TIME DELAY, IT
TRANSFERS A DEFICIT TO THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION, WHICH ALSO KIND
OF DOESN'T SEEM FAIR, BUT IT
ALSO IT JUST ADDS TO THE
CHALLENGE THAT I ARTICULATED
WHEN I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
BUDGET BILL ITSELF. LASTLY, THE
APPORTIONMENT FACTOR. WE HAD
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS
AND SOMEWHAT CONFUSING IN OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEETING
YESTERDAY, BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS, AS I POINTED OUT THEN
AND EVERYONE AGREED, THIS IS NOT
A DEFERRAL. THIS IS A TAX
INCREASE. IT IS AN INCREASE IN
TAXES WHICH REQUIRES A TWO
THIRDS MAJORITY VOTE AT THE
BUDGET, OF COURSE, WILL BE
PASSED BY A SIMPLE MAJORITY, AND
, IT, IT ALSO, BASICALLY
INVALIDATES THE AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS. THESE
PROPOSALS ARE FLAWED FOR ALL
SORTS OF REASONS. I URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR NELSON.
SENATOR DOLLY, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'LL BE BRIEF. I JUST
WANTED TO ADD, SOME THOUGHTS
THAT, STRUCTURALLY FOR
CALIFORNIA NEED TO BE ADDRESSED,
THAT, CALIFORNIA TYPICALLY DOES.
WELL, BECAUSE OF THE CAPITAL
GAINS THAT WE RECEIVE OFF OF THE
WORLDWIDE COMPANIES THAT ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. CAPITAL GAINS TAX
WHEN THE STOCK MARKET IS DOING
WELL. AND SO I WANT TO MAKE THE
POINT THAT THE STOCK MARKET IS
DOING WELL. THE NASDAQ HAS
EXCEEDED ITS LIMITS OR ITS ALL
TIME HIGHS. AND SO IS THE
NASDAQ. AND SO WHAT HAS HAPPENED
IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE HAVE A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND MOST
OTHER STATES DON'T HAVE RIGHT
NOW. WHY IS THAT? THAT'S THE
QUESTION THAT NEEDS TO BE
ANSWERED. WHY IS THAT? AND IT'S
QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE OF BILLS
LIKE SB 167, WHICH ARE
PENALIZING BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. NOT ONLY ARE WE THE
HIGHEST TAXED, BUT WE'RE THE
HIGHEST REGULATED. WE HAVE A LOT
OF POLICIES THAT COME THROUGH
THIS HOUSE THAT TELL YOU HOW
MANY EMPLOYEES YOU HAVE TO HAVE,
VERSUS A CHECKOUT IN YOUR STORE
OR WHAT THE MINIMUM WAGE IS
GOING TO BE IN YOUR BUSINESS.
THOSE ARE ALL REGULATORY TAXES
OR, REGULATIONS THAT HURT
BUSINESS. SO I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT AMERICA IS DOING
WELL. STOCK MARKET'S ALL TIME
HIGHS, NASDAQ'S ALL TIME HIGHS.
AND CALIFORNIA IS NOT DOING
WELL. SO YOU NEED TO BE ON
NOTICE THAT THERE'S A HUGE
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT'S NOT GOING
TO GET BETTER UNTIL WE HELP
BUSINESSES STAY IN CALIFORNIA,
WHICH PAY THE ORIGINAL TAX. FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING SB 167. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THE BUSINESSES A BREAK.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DOLLY. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING NONE. SENATOR WIENER, YOU
MAY CLOSE, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I AGREE AMERICA IS
DOING WELL. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER. SO THANK
YOU, PRESIDENT BIDEN, FOR
DELIVERING SUCH AN AMAZING
ECONOMY, SO I WANT TO JUST
STRESS THAT IN TERMS OF THESE,
THIS IS NOT AN A, AN ELIMINATION
OF THESE CREDITS. YES, THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO RECOUP THEM, IN THE
FUTURE, AND YOU KNOW, I ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY IN TERMS OF
TAXATION, I SAID THIS IN
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY, IT WAS ONLY
SEVEN YEARS AGO, IN 2017, THAT
THE FEDERAL CORPORATE TAX RATE
WAS REDUCED BY 40% FROM 35% TO
21. IT'S A HUGE BOON. WE NOW
HAVE LARGE CORPORATIONS, A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER, LARGE
CORPORATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY WHO
LITERALLY PAY NO FEDERAL TAXES
IN TERMS OF CORPORATE TAX OR
VERY LITTLE. AND SO ALL WE ARE
ASKING HERE DURING A DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEAR IS TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION THAT THEY'LL GET,
THEY'LL GET THE MONEY, THEY'LL
GET THE CREDITS LATER. BUT BE A
PART OF THE EFFORT TO BALANCE
THIS BUDGET. THIS IS A VERY
REASONABLE APPROACH, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ALL DEBATE. HAVING THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO NO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER I WILL. NO. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
I'LL RODA-GIL. AYE. A VOTE OF 29
TO 8 ON THE URGENCY. 29 TO 8.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FROM UNFINISHED
BUSINESS TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. WE HAVE ONE ITEM.
EXCUSE ME. SENATE THIRD READING.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM TO CONSIDER.
THERE THAT'S FILE ITEM 61. THIS
IS SCR 15 BY SENATOR ALLEN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 157 BY
SENATOR ALLEN RELATIVE TO
DIRECTING THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO WITHDRAW FROM THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SENATE.
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT NUMBER
TWO OF THE 20 2122 REGULAR
SESSION RELATING TO PUBLIC
HOUSING PROJECTS. SENATOR ALLEN,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS THIS THIS SEEKS TO PULL
BACK THE QUESTION OF ARTICLE 34
REPEAL FROM THE NEXT BALLOT.
ARTICLE 34 WAS ADDED TO THE
CONSTITUTION IN 1950 TO PROHIBIT
THE DEVELOPMENT AND CONSTRUCTION
OR ACQUISITION OF LOW RENT
HOUSING PROJECTS BY ANY
GOVERNMENT ENTITY UNTIL APPROVED
BY VOTERS, BUILDING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING QUICKLY IS A
PRIORITY. WE INTRODUCED SCA TWO,
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO TO PUT THE
REPEAL OF ARTICLE 34 ON THE
BALLOT, AS ONE OF MANY EFFORTS
TO HELP ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS. I ALSO AUTHORED SB 469
LAST YEAR, WHICH SUBSTANTIALLY
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
ARTICLE 34 MIGHT BE IMPACTING
HOUSING PRODUCTION. THIS IS A
VERY CROWDED BALLOT. THERE ARE
ROUGHLY A DOZEN MEASURES ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT. REACHING VOTERS
WILL BE DIFFICULT AND EXPENSIVE.
WE KNEW WHEN WE MADE THIS
DECISION LAST SESSION TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS, THAT THIS
WOULD BE A POSSIBLE TOOL IN OUR
TOOL KIT TO PULL IT BACK.
PENDING WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH
SB 469 AND WHAT THE BALLOT WAS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE, WE ALL
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY THAT
ARTICLE 34 SHOULD BE REPEALED
FROM THE CONSTITUTION, BUT THAT
THE TIMING OF SCA TWO IS
SUBOPTIMAL AND WITHOUT THE
URGENT NEED WITH AND WITH THE
MANY COMPETING BALLOT PRIORITIES
, IT'S BEST TO PULL SCA TWO FROM
THE BALLOT RATHER THAN WASTE
TIME, EFFORT AND RESOURCES ON A
MEASURE, THAT WOULD BE REALLY
RATHER UNPREDICTABLE AS TO ITS
PASSAGE. SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
SEEKS TO DO. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ALLEN. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE? MEMBERS,
LET ME REMIND YOU, THIS MEASURE
DOES REQUIRE 27 VOTES. SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ELLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
COBO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. S¼
SATO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE
. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
. ALVARADO. GILL. DALLEY GROVE.
JONES LIMÓN. NGUYEN NILO. MATOBO
SATO. STERN. ALL RIGHT. ON A
VOTE OF 30 TO 0, THE MEASURE
PASSES. EXCUSE ME. MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR. THEY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. WE'LL MOVE
TO REPORTS OF COMMITTEE. THEY'LL
BE DEEMED READ. AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. FIRST, RECOGNIZE THE
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW SENATE BILL
1381 FROM ENGROSSING AND
ENROLLING AND RETURN THE MEASURE
TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER
ACTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION, I'LL
BE THE ORDER OF THE DAY. ME TURN
NEXT TO SENATOR DODD. DO YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT, AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE AB
1945, ITEM NUMBER 136 FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALSO AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE AB 2849. THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER 48 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
FILE ITEM 126 AB 2146 BY
RODRIGUEZ AND FILE ITEM 147 AB
2822 GABRIEL BE REMOVED FOR FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE SENATOR
CIERTO I HAVE TWO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW SB
1122 FROM ENGROSSING AND
ENROLLING AND RETURN THE MEASURE
TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER
ACTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THAT
WILL BE THE ORDER. SENATOR ALL
RIGHT. I WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
SCR 111 FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE DESK WILL NOTE. SENATOR
BECKER. YES I'D LIKE TO AT THE
REQUEST, THE AUTHOR PULL FILE
ITEM 120 AB2251. CONNOLLY FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE DESK
WILL NOTE SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
REQUEST. REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM 138 AB
1986 FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS, THE
DESK WILL NOTE SENATOR WEINER, I
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I MOVE
ADOPTION OF AUTHOR'S AMENDMENTS
FOR BUDGET BILLS AND BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS THAT CROSS THE
DESK ON FRIDAY, SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY, JUNE 14TH, 15TH AND 16TH
2024. THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ADOPTED, PUBLISHED AND THE BILL
IS RETURNED TO THE COMMITTEE. SO
THIS IS A MOTION FOR AN
AMENDMENT. WELL, WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL. VOTE ON IT. IT IS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
MATTER. SENATOR NILO, I OBJECT
TO THE MOTION. OKAY. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OAN AYE. ALL RODA-GIL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NO DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OTOBO NO.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GIL. LIMÓN. STERN ON A
VOTE OF 29 TO 8. THE MOTION
CARRIES MEMBERS PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE 29.10 B, FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES FILE ITEM
103, AB 1186, PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE 2910 C, THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. FILE ITEM 104, AB 996.
FILE ITEM 105, AB 0628. FILE
ITEM 106, AB 1239, FILE ITEM
107, AB 799 AND FILE ITEM 108 AB
863 MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
CLERK, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1853 2234 WITH AMENDMENTS
2290, WITH AMENDMENTS 2289, WITH
AMENDMENTS 20 2333, WITH
AMENDMENTS 23, 25, 25, 97. THE
SECOND READING FILE WILL BE
DEEMED READ NEXT UP, MEMBERS, IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. TO
RECONCILE. OKAY, WE'LL TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IN JUST A
MOMENT. MEMBERS. AND JUST TO
MAKE MEMBERS AWARE, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO DO ADJOURN IN MEMORIES
TODAY. SO I KNOW THAT WAS ON THE
DOCKET FOR SOME APOLOGIES FOR
THAT.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP TWO CONSENT CALENDARS.
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. DOES ANY
MEMBER WANT TO REMOVE ANYTHING
FROM EITHER THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 23,
70, 24, 29, 30, 90. ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION 12. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1916 1941 2301. SENATE.
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 143.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1774, 1796, 1805,
1821, 1871, 1875, 1957, 21,
1121, 73, 21, 77, 21, 79, 22,
13, 22, 61, 23, 45, 25, 41, 30,
92, 32, 77. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 124 158 177 187 198
199 200. INCIDENTALLY,
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 201. ALL
RIGHT, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE OR
DATO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE AYE.
PODIUM AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
ALLEN AYE. RODA-GIL. LIMÓN.
STERN IT'S A VOTE OF 37 TO 0 ON
FILE ITEM ONE 2037 TO 0 ON THE
BALANCE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDARS. MEMBERS. IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE. SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MR.
PRESIDENT. I KNOW THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY BUSY TIME OF THE
YEAR. STRESSFUL BILLS, MOVING
THROUGH COMMITTEES. I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSTANT WORK TO EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE. WE WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
BUDGET VOTES NEXT WEEK. HERE ON
THE FLOOR. FOLKS SHOULD BE
PREPARED FOR THAT. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY, JUNE 17TH AT 2 P.M. HAVE
A GOOD WEEKEND. THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY, JUNE 17TH AT 2
P.M.